Untertitel der Amara.org-Community
tatsächlich auch nach Jahrzehnten immer noch die GameStar-Reviews am besten. Die decken sich meistens so
grob mit dem, was ich über irgendwelche Games denke.
Natürlich gibt es da auch ein paar Reinfälle, aber das geht schon ganz gut klar.
Aber für so Langzeitsachen kann man eigentlich bei den ganzen Reviews immer nicht wirklich, wirklich drauf verlassen und ich denke,
gibt halt die einen Leute, die einfach mal wieder Diablo-Kampagnen durchspielen wollen,
Diablo bashen und dann ist gut.
Und es gibt halt andere, die hoffen sich ein Game, was sie jetzt irgendwie
die nächsten Jahre über immer mal wieder spielen können oder teilweise Monate durchgängig.
Das muss sich halt tatsächlich langfristig zeigen und man muss halt auch mal gucken,
ob sich Blizzard nicht noch irgendeine Monetarisierungsstrategie da
aus dem Ärmel schüttelt, die einem nicht gefällt.
Ausbildungssuche läuft bei dir heute Absage erhalten. Echt? Es gibt noch sowas wie Absagen?
Ich dachte, die nehmen aktuell einfach jeden...
Na gut, Ausbildung. Achso, Ausbildung. Ja gut, das suckt natürlich.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie es mit der Activision Blizzard-Übernahme von
Microsoft aussieht.
Das letzte war ja so nach dem Motto, Aufsicht bei den Amis muss noch zustimmen.
Dann hat die Aufsicht bei den Amis gesagt, ach ne, so geil finden sie das doch nicht.
Unter diesen und diesen Gesichtspunkten jetzt müssen wir noch irgendwas machen. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was da was da rausgekommen ist
Der UK juckt die nicht
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was da rausgekommen ist, aber ich denke mal das läuft immer noch
Und mittlerweile muss ich fast sagen, so blöd es klingt und Microsoft ist ja nur wirklich
Ich meine, es kann mir keiner sagen
dass ich irgendwie großer Microsoft-Fan bin, ja?
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, viele...
Also gerade Blizzard, die haben ja wirklich...
Ich frag mich, was die auf ihrer BlizzCon machen wollten.
Oder was die auf ihrer BlizzCon machen.
Dieses Jahr ist wieder eine BlizzCon.
Ich weiß nicht, was die da zeigen wollen.
Grasball wachsen zugucken, oder wie?
Die haben ja eigentlich...
Na gut, Diablo 4 können sie jetzt ein bisschen was zeigen, ja?
Okay. Und neue Projekte, ich bin ja mal skeptisch,
skeptisch, ob da irgendwas kommt. Vielleicht gibt es ja noch einen PVE-Modus für Overwatch 3 jetzt bald.
Mit Zeit, sie könnten, vom Entwicklungszyklus wird es passen. Sie kündigen Overwatch 3 mit PVE an.
Ansonsten bin ich mal gespannt, ob da irgendwas Nennenswertes kommt.
Ansonsten, ich glaube es wäre gar nicht so schlecht, wenn Microsoft da mal ein bisschen frischen Wind reinbringt. Allerdings
darf man halt nicht vergessen, ganz ehrlich Leute,
Leute, man lässt sich da immer so hinreißen dazu.
Ah ja, die bringen jetzt frisch Lünfer, dann kommen wieder gute Games.
Microsoft ist das auch in Wirklichkeit alles scheißegal.
Solange der Rubel rollt, ist Microsoft auch happy.
Also die sind nicht, das ist, man muss sich jetzt nicht davon erhoffen,
dass die irgendwie die Gameserien retten, die einem am Herzen liegen.
Das kannst du, kannst knicken.
Immer, guck mal, wann haben die Bethesda übernommen?
Äh, wo...
Äh, wann war'n wir es?
Oder C-C-Cenimax muss man ja eigentlich sagen.
Ja, vor ungefähr- ungefähr 2 Jahren.
Und vom neuen Elder Scrolls hat man immer noch nix gehört.
Ich mein, das einzige was du gehört hast von Elder Scrolls 6 war,
vor, keine Ahnung, 5 Jahren oder so,
Mal den Schriftzug Elder Scrolls 6 und so und und das Main Theme drei Töne fertig
Also ob da irgendwas zu zumindest habe ich jetzt letzterzeit nichts nichts mehr davon gehört
Nö ich bin ich bin mal gespannt ich bin ich bin mal gespannt
Was ist bald?
Also die Blizzcon ist im November.
Ach, das Xbox Showcase.
Also bevor, bevor Elderscrolls 6 kommt, kommt tatsächlich Skyrim noch für Fitness Tracker
oder sowas.
Ja, gehe ich auch von aus.
Ich meine, Skyrim wird für jede Plattform kommen, für die es noch nicht da ist, bevor
Elder Scrolls 6 rauskommt.
Ja, für Drucker, für Schwangerschaftstests, für Etikettenprinter, alles.
Die Übernahme scheitert ja meistens nicht, weil die nicht miteinander können, sondern
Weil irgendwelche Behörden sagen, sie sehen da zu viel einseitig in dem Markt.
Ja, ansonsten, ob die miteinander können oder nicht, das geht denen doch am Arsch vorbei.
Also ob die EU da was dagegen hat, weiß ich nicht.
Ich weiß, dass diese Aufsichtsbehörde bei den Amis etwas dagegen hat, gegen die Activision Blizzard, äh nicht Activision Blizzard, gegen die Microsoft Activision Blizzard Übernahme.
Ich weiß aber nicht, was da da aktuell zustande ist. Ich hab schon ein paar Tage nicht mehr geguckt. Ich glaube nicht, dass da was groß getan hat.
Eclipse schreibt, ich muss Microsoft aber in ihren C-Sharp.net Projekten gut herumfinden.
Ey, muss man sagen, also .NET, generell, also seitdem sie .NET neu entwickelt haben, ist das sehr angenehm, da drin zu programmieren.
Auch Visual Studio Code ist nice. Vieles, was Microsoft macht, ist nice, allerdings vieles auch scheiße, Windows vorne weg.
Also es gibt viele Sachen, die mich aufregen bei Microsoft, aber Microsoft macht auch gute Sachen.
Ich finde, bei Microsoft merkt man extrem, dass es zwar eine Firma ist, also unter diesem Microsoft-Namen,
aber intern total viele unterschiedliche kuppchen geben geben
diese alle bis in den ding machen
bin ich ein vietnamer er
obviously
bin vietnamer
ich bewegt mich noch gar nicht deswegen ist die katze so so ruhig
was steht heute an
Versuche nicht einzuschlafen
Sieben stunden quick maths auch nicht schlecht bekommt ja auch die absurdesten jobangebote auf linkedin und co
Zeigt mal eins
Box box rox dankeschön für den sub
Ich glaube du bist das erste mal in den zweiten monat da schön dass du einen weg her gefunden hast
Vermutlich, du kommst von YouTube, oder? Kommst du von YouTube?
Oder hast du hier auf Twitch das Ganze gefunden?
Bilde mir ein, ich hab dich schon mal auf YouTube irgendwo in den Comments gesehen.
Ne, also, ich hab ja keinen privaten LinkedIn-Account.
Ich glaube, ich bin so ziemlich der einzige... Zufallstreffer, okay, dann hab ich mich vertan.
Ich glaube, ich bin ja so ziemlich der Einzige, der im IT-Sektor tätig ist und keinen privaten LinkedIn-Account hat.
Wobei, naja, kann man nicht so sagen. Ich habe einen Fake-LinkedIn-Account mit einem Anime-Bild drinnen und die haben sie nicht gelöscht.
Aber ich habe da auch ewig nicht mehr reingeguckt und keine Ahnung, weiß nicht, was es da so gibt.
Aber ich weiß, ich weiß von meinem Kollege, der bekommt immer irgendwelche komischen
Headhunter-Anfragen auf LinkedIn, immer noch, obwohl er mittlerweile sogar drinsteht, dass er wieder einen Job hat und alles.
Und da ist so viel Schwachsinn dabei, das stimmt.
Ja, das hat er auch erzählt.
PowerShell macht Spaß, bin von Badge... Ja gut.
Ja, okay.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, anstelle von Badge
macht alles Spaß.
Sogar Visual Basic in Office
macht Spaß gegen Badge.
PowerShell ist nice, allerdings finde ich,
ist PowerShell eine ziemlich miese Shell
zum
drinnen arbeiten
PowerShell ist für Automatisierungssachen nice
aber täglich quasi
nur in PowerShell meine Arbeit
erledigen möchte ich auch nicht
da benutze ich lieber
meine Linux
ZSH oder meinetwegen auch Bash
also auf PowerShell habe ich keinen Bock
ich hatte auch noch nie das Verlangen ehrlich gesagt
auf dem Linux System PowerShell nachzuinstallieren
das geht ja
wissen ja auch einige nicht
ist ja mittlerweile lauffähig unter unter linux und windows und und ehrlich
gesagt wahrscheinlich auch mac os ich weiß es gar nicht aber ich kenne
niemand der powershell unter linux macht warum auch ich habe aber gehört bei mir
auf der arbeit wollen sie jetzt microsoft sql unter linux laufen lassen
Da, als erstes, da dachte ich mir auch, Alter.
Nooo, God!
No, God, please, no!
Also nicht, dass es schlechter wäre, Microsoft SQL unter Linux laufen zu lassen als unter Windows.
Das Blöde daran ist bloß, dass sich dann Linux-Leute drum kümmern müssen.
Und wenn das schön weiterläuft unter Windows, dann haben wir es wenigstens von der Backe.
Ich such keinen neuen Job, das ist richtig.
Okay, gibt es immer noch Probleme bei Microsoft und Activision, ja.
Ja, mach das mal.
Also, ganz ehrlich, wenn du die Auswahl hast, was zu programmieren in Batch oder in Visual
Basic, dann würde ich es auf jeden Fall in Visual Basic machen, weil ich meine Visual
Immerhin noch ne... ne... was als Programmiersprache gedacht ist.
Ja, nice.
Ja gut, ich mein, wenn du was haben willst, könntest du es ja auch aktualisieren.
Aber das meiste ist eh Schrott.
Ich hab gesehen, bei uns auf der Arbeit gibt es zwei neue Stellen, die ausgeschrieben wurden.
Ich sage euch jetzt nicht welche genau, sonst könnt ihr googeln und wisst genau wie ich arbeite.
Ähm, und...
Habe ich jetzt gleich erstmal zwei Ex-Kollegen geschickt von der alten Arbeit.
Mal gucken ob die da Bock drauf haben, können sich bewerben.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, ich habe da mittlerweile schon so viele vermittelt.
Also wirklich vermittelt habe ich ja nur einen, aber ich habe schon öfters mal angemerkt,
Ich kenn da jemand, die müssen mir ein bisschen mehr als die normale Prämie geben, glaub mittlerweile.
Die sollten mir auch sowas geben, wenn ich da einen vermittel, was so ein Headhunter bekommt.
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Hälfte vom ersten Jahresgehalt oder sowas. Easy.
Wie viel Prämie gibt's? Ähm, ja, so um die 2000 Euro.
Es ist weniger, es ist weniger. Es ist ne Ecke weniger als...
Ich will es dir aber nicht genau sagen, weil vielleicht kann man das googeln und findet das dann.
Ja, das ist so ein Mitarbeiter-Werbe-Mitarbeiter-Programm.
Die meisten Leute, die würde ich persönlich sogar ganz ohne Prämie empfehlen, weil bis jetzt, also ich bin jetzt zwei Monate,
sind das wieder Linux-Jobs?
Auch, auch, ja, es ist Linux, Netzwerk, Cloud, alles mögliche dabei.
Ja und die Leute, die Leute würde ich wahrscheinlich auch ohne jegliche Prämie vermitteln, also
erstens finde ich es jetzt nach zwei Monaten ganz nice da, so dass ich es den anderen empfehlen
würde und allein schon weil sie, weil sie dort sogar eine ganze Ecke mehr verdienen
als im alten Job.
Ich weiß ja, was sie ungefähr geklickt haben und auch super reinpassen würden, würde
ich die vermitteln.
Aber gut, die müssen erstmal wollen, ich hab denen vorhin mal ne Message geschrieben übers Handy, aber es hat noch keiner, hat sich noch keiner gerührt bisher von denen, insofern, oh.
Ganz leise, kannst du inzwischen arbeiten oder ist der Laptop immer noch zugenagelt?
Ja, ich kann arbeiten, aber der Laptop ist immer noch zugenagelt.
Ich habe eine eigene Linux-VM, auf der ich Root bin.
Ich habe quasi auf meinem Notebook bloß ein Terminal im Fullscreen, das geht.
Aber schön ist es trotzdem nicht.
Ich muss da auch ein bisschen mehr meckern, dass man mal, dass alle mitbekommen, wie painstjampig
das ist.
Du verwendest PowerShell unter Linux?
Ja, okay.
Okay, fürs Administrieren von irgendwelchen Microsoft-Sachen kann ich's verstehen.
Ja, das leuchtet ja ein, das verstehe ich schon, allerdings da benutzt du es ja auch quasi für was, wo es irgendwie so ein bisschen Alleinstellungsmerkmal hat, ich meinte jetzt halt einfach PowerShell unter Linux für so tägliche Admin-Arbeit, das wäre mir nix, da bleibe ich bei den klassischen Shells, einfach ein bisschen wegen der Gewöhnung und da habe ich alles, ich kann die ganzen Linux-Tools ordentlich benutzen,
Ich brauche kein find-str-v-irgendwas, wie das in PowerShell ist.
PowerShell ist vom Ansatz her cool.
Dadurch, dass du nicht Text pipst, sondern dort net Objekte pipst und dann auf Properties zugreifen kannst.
Ganz ehrlich, aber mir ist eine einfache Shell mit Text raus und Text rein immer noch am liebsten.
Zum täglichen interaktiven Arbeiten.
Ja, für solche Sachen leuchtet es mir irgendwo ein.
Danke für den Sub, Hogu!
Erster Monat, das ist ja extremly nice.
Ne, also bei uns gibt's, bei uns gibt's, wobei 32 Tage Urlaub würden sie wahrscheinlich noch mit sich reden lassen.
Aber 100% Homeoffice wirst du bei uns nicht kriegen, ich bin trotzdem gewechselt, weil es immer noch eine wahnsinns Verbesserung ist.
Und zwar bei meinem alten Job haben sie ja angefangen während der Corona-Zeit, habe ich euch schon oft genug erzählt, aber nur mal kurz, ne.
Während der Corona-Zeit haben sie ja da angefangen, oh ja Homeoffice und so, wir haben jetzt super tolle Regelungen und sobald Corona halbwegs vorbei war,
haben sie diese ganzen Regelungen wieder eingestampft und ohne irgendwie großartig was zu sagen.
Also, das war dann am Ende. Jetzt ist es aktuell so, bei der alten Arbeit, habe ich letztens von einem Ex-Kolleg gehört,
die wollen, dass die Leute wieder quasi jeden Tag kommen und es gibt nur maximal ein Tag die Woche Homeoffice,
in Ausnahmefällen zwei, wenn man ganz gute Begründungen hat.
Und das ist halt echt nicht das, was ich mir vorgestellt habe da quasi.
Ach ja, und sie machen auch keinen Unterschied zwischen Teilzeitarbeitenden und Vollzeitarbeitenden.
Also sprich, ich mit 80% hätte genauso oft hingemusst, wie einer der 100% arbeitet und das haben sie wirklich richtig beschissen gemacht.
Deswegen finden die im alten Unternehmen, wo ich gearbeitet habe, auch niemand.
Das habe ich letztes Jahr auch wieder gehört.
Da wird gefragt im Vorstellungsgespräch von den Bewerbern, wie sieht es bei Ihnen mit Homeoffice-Regelung aus?
Und dann sagen die, ja gibt es nicht und dann sagt er, ja tschüss, dann gehe ich woanders hin.
Und deswegen bin ich auch gewechselt. Das war eines der Hauptgründe, warum ich gewechselt bin.
Und wir haben aktuell nur die Vorgabe, und das ist tatsächlich die einzige Vorgabe, die existiert,
dass wir im Durchschnitt über einen Monat gesehen einmal die Woche da sein sollen.
Theoretisch könnte man jetzt argumentieren, ja gut, bei mir mit 80%,
Ja, wenn sie mal eine Woche nicht so ist, ist auch nicht wild, juckt aber auch keinen.
Ich meine, viele von den Leuten bei mir kommen sogar nur alle zwei Wochen.
Also insofern...
Eine Woche Dasein, drei Wochen mobil, das könntest du machen, das könntest du machen.
Klar, manche Teams haben solche Sachen, wie einmal mittwochs ist Teamrunde, wird gerne gesehen, wenn man da ist.
Aber ist in meinem Team zum Beispiel nicht so. Bei mir ist es vollkommen frei, welcher Tag man kommt.
Und ob du mal eine Woche daheim bleibst und dann zwei Tage da, bist du so interessiert? Keins. Es hat mich noch nicht einer genervt damit.
Also, die scheinen das wirklich ernst zu nehmen, ja? Die haben mir das gesagt, so ist es. Ich halte mich da dran und es gibt keine Probleme und keinen Sturz, ja?
Also, Geld würdest du easy kriegen bei uns, allerdings 100% Homeoffice würdest du nicht geben.
geben ok 32 32 tage urlaub kann ich dir nicht sagen wie viel wie viel wie viel
sie wahrscheinlich also standardmäßig nicht aber vielleicht wenn du das
verhandelst warum nicht wenn es halt was ist
große händeringend leute suchen
der juniorenmarkt ist etwas schwieriger also bei uns finden die nirgendswo leute
die finden bei uns keine senior leute die finden uns bei uns auch keine
Einsteiger und normalen Leute finden gar nichts.
Ich hab letztens gesehen, wir haben glaube ich insgesamt fünf Admin-Stellen oder so offen
und
Nee, mehr, mehr, mehr Admin-Stellen. Ich glaube sieben, ich glaube alleine vier oder fünf Senior-Stellen haben wir offen
und noch ein paar
Juniors, in dem Fall gibt es bei uns nicht. Das heißt dann halt einfach ganz normal, wie die Berufsbezeichnung, die sie suchen
Und die sind, die sind schon ewig offen, da bewirbt sich einfach keiner drauf oder ja vielleicht bewirbt sich ab und zu mal einer und die taugen gar nix, weiß nicht, also die finden überhaupt niemand.
Ja schick mal rüber, ja schick, Darkside schick, schick rüber.
Kenn ich gar nicht.
Was für einen Application-Launcher benutzt du unter i3?
Du meinst das hier vermute ich mal.
Moment.
Ja, ist gut.
Ich guck gleich.
Du meinst nicht meine Leiste, sondern du meinst das Popup-Ding, ne?
Also quasi...
Du meinst das hier.
Wo man auch hier unten noch Fenster suchen kann und Emojis einfügen kann und sonst was.
Ähm...
Das nennt sich Rofi oder Rofi oder wie auch immer Rofi wahrscheinlich.
Keine Ahnung, GitHub.
Man musste aber, da musste aber einiges customizen.
Standardmäßig sieht das Ding sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig aus auf jeden Fall.
Guck mal, es gab schon lange keinen Release mehr.
Kann man aber auch extrem customisen, das Ding.
D-Menü ist auch vollkommen okay.
Also wenn dir das reicht, man muss es ja nicht übertreiben, als sein muss, ne?
Was ist eigentlich mit deinen alten .files im Arch, die gibt es noch, die gibt es noch,
guck mal.
Dort feils und dann gehst du hier unter
Old dort feils
Habe ich wenigstens mal gescheit benannt
Da hast du die noch
Da gibt es auch noch hier die i3 status rust konfig kann aber sein dass die mit der aktuellen version gar nicht gar nicht mehr geht
Hört sich so an, als gibt es kaum noch Leute, die bei deinem alten Laden arbeiten, das ist korrekt.
Also, es sind sehr viele gegangen und viele, die von denen da sind, wo ich jetzt gehört habe, sind quasi kurz vorm Abhauen.
Ja, da ging es bzw. geht es richtig, richtig den Bach runter.
Und wisst ihr, was ich witzig jetzt gehört habe?
Ähm, nachdem sie ja ein komplettes Team dort zumachen wollen, schwebt ihnen vor, dass die Arbeit, die das Team gemacht hat, jetzt von, also die hatten da so ein 24-7-Team.
Ich hab immer gesagt, das ist der Support, das stimmt nicht, das war nicht wirklich der Support, das war eher so eine Art Operation Center, also die waren 24-7 im Schichtbetrieb da,
haben Systeme überwacht, haben eskaliert, wenn Meldungen gekommen sind, haben erste Analyse gemacht, wenn was kaputt gegangen ist, haben Wartungsarbeiten nachts durchgeführt und sowas, ja.
Das war eh ein Operation Center. Ich hab die immer Support genannt.
Ne, nicht wirklich Service, ich hab die immer Support genannt, aber es ist eigentlich so, ich glaub offiziell heißen die auch Operation Center.
So, und das wollen sie dicht machen. Und wisst ihr, warum sie das dicht machen? Das ist eigentlich ganz witzig, weil, ähm, weil sie keine Leute finden
Und sie die Leute, die dort gearbeitet haben, so schlecht behandelt haben, dass sie abgehauen sind.
Und jetzt können sie sagen, wir können den Schichtbetrieb nicht aufrechterhalten, weil uns die Leute wegrennen.
So als wären die Leute, die abhauen, die Bösen.
Hättet ihr euch angestrengt, dann hättet ihr neue Leute gefunden, die alten Leute werden euch nicht abgehauen.
Zumindest machen sie da jetzt dicht.
Und sie haben einen Dienstleister, Händering, gesucht, der die Arbeiten übernimmt.
Und jetzt haben sie wohl, also wie gesagt, ich höre das immer noch um drei Ecken, ja, von dem da an, wo ich gearbeitet habe.
Und jetzt haben sie einen Dienstleister gefunden, der sich dazu bereit erklärt hat, das zu übernehmen.
Und jetzt kam halt im Nachhinein raus, dass der Dienstleister nichts macht, außer Ticket-Handling.
Also das Einzige, was der Dienstleister macht, ist Monitoring meldet, Service, Applikation, Server, was auch immer hat Probleme.
Und dann, ja, keine Ahnung, machen die ein Störungsticket und vielleicht, wenn es eine Eskalationsliste gibt, versuchen die nachts einen anzurufen. Fertig, das war's.
Good luck, have fun!
Ist der Dienstleister Bechtle? Ne, aber ich glaube die haben sich das auch angeguckt.
JSDLAN, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ne, also, das geht da total den Bach runter.
Und der Dienstleister wird das halt alles, ich sag dir nicht welche das ist, der Dienstleister wird das alles super nach Vorschrift machen, wenn da irgendwie ein Monitoring falsch konfiguriert ist und nachts 3.000 Notifications schickt, dann machen die 3.000 Ticket auf, die rufen 3.000 mal an und die schicken auch wenn es sein muss 3.000 SMS Notifications, weil es so in den SLRs drin steht, da kennen die nix, so ist es halt wenn du Dienstleister hast, die sich halt nicht dafür interessieren.
Beziehungsweise, die ist halt einfach stur nach
Aha, so ist es geregelt, so machen wir das
Es hat schon durchaus seinen Sinn, sowas im Haus zu haben
Die haben das ja extra aufgebaut vor ein paar Jahren
Jetzt wird's wieder abgeschafft, also richtig bescheuert
Und sind selbst dran schuld
Den rennen halt nicht nur dort die Leute weg
Ich weiß, dass in meinem alten Team ganz viele Leute, ähm
Also, ich bin ja schon weg
Äh, noch einer ist Ende des Monats weg
Ähm, im anderen noch mehr, egal
Zumindest ganz viele anderen haben auch keinen Bock mehr
Was machst du so im Daily Business? Ich kann dir sagen, was ich heute gemacht habe zum Beispiel, wenn du willst
Pixel Black
Ich kann dir sagen, was ich heute gemacht habe. Heute habe ich viereinhalb Stunden versucht
einen Helm Install Script beziehungsweise einen Helm Chart
Ich versuche mal kurz zu erklären, wer das nicht kennt
Helm ist ein Installer oder ein Package-Manager für Kubernetes.
Also wenn du eine Anwendung in deinem Kubernetes starten willst,
dann ist es meistens so, dass die Hersteller, also egal was ihr benutzt,
Hersteller liefern in der Regel irgendwelche Packages mit oder irgendwelche Install-Skripts mit.
Und im Kubernetes-Umfeld liefern die Helm-Charts bzw. Helm-Templates mit.
Das ist quasi ein Installer, könnte man so sagen.
Und von der Idee her ist das so, du musst halt nichts machen, außer dass du wie bei einem Installer einstellst so, welche Ports sollen die Anwendung benutzen, welche Repos sollen die benutzen, welche URLs sollen sie für den Ingress, also du hast so einen Values-File, da gibst du an, wie bei einem Installer im Endeffekt, wie du die Anwendung einrichten willst und dann lässt du Helm das quasi deployen in deinen Kubernetes-Cluster.
Und dann unter der Haube sind das halt Go-Templates, und die Werte, die du halt in deinem Installer gesetzt hast, werden dann an der richtigen Stelle eingesetzt
und es kommen Config-Files raus, die man in Kooperative Supplyen kann.
Dafür ist Helm.
So, und ich habe heute viereinhalb Stunden versucht, mit noch drei anderen Leuten komplett verbuggte, ungetestete Helm-Install-Packages vom Hersteller zu deployen.
Und wir sind zu dem Schluss gekommen, als wir angefangen haben, in den Template-Files rumzuwursten, in denen man eigentlich nichts machen muss,
ja, weil wie gesagt, das ist ja eigentlich ein Installer, die Templates macht der Hersteller, sind wir zu dem Schluss gekommen, die haben den Kram nie getestet.
Ja, die Secrets heißen falsch, die Namensauflösung ist falsch, komplett ungetesteter Shit, den sie uns da geschickt haben.
Das haben wir heute versucht, viereinhalb Stunden zu fixen.
Zwischendurch war ich noch mal kurz auf meiner Teamrunde und dann war ich noch auf was essen und das war es eigentlich.
Also mit viereinhalb Stunden den Kram angeguckt, das hat mir auch echt gereicht. So ein richtiger Crap, man.
Dann hatte ich noch einen Projekt-Daily von einer Viertelstunde, einen Weekly-Termin,
sowas gibt's neues, kurz Team-Runde und dann heute Mittag nochmal irgend so ein Start-Projekt-Status-Meeting.
Also wirklich gemacht habe ich nichts, wir haben versucht die Installer, die Helm-Install-Packages
zu fixen, dass sie gehen, wir haben es im Endeffekt allerdings nicht hinbekommen, wobei
ich sagen muss wir wären nichts weit davon entfernt gewesen also wir waren
noch nie so nah dran es zum laufen zu bekommen
wir haben gesagt es ist nicht unser job den kaputten installer des herstellers
zu fixen sondern wir melden das an den hersteller
was sie eben ihre installer installern ganz machen sollen
Also das wäre bei uns möglich, ja?
Das heißt, du kannst, ja, kannst du machen, kannst du machen.
Wie gesagt, sofern das, also bei mir im Team wäre das möglich, bei anderen weiß ich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich.
Okay.
Karriere, was?
Milch und Zucker?
Ist das Tibet?
Ne, okay.
Was ist, was ist das?
Milch und Zucker?
Ist das Tibet?
Ne, okay.
Was ist, was ist das?
Milch und Zucker?
Was ist das? Milch und Zucker?
Ach, das ist ein Personalvermittler, oder was?
Milch und Zucker, geiler Name.
Okay, was soll ich mir jetzt angucken, das hier?
Systemadministrator, Linux, männlich-weiß...
Keine Ahnung.
Milch und Zucker steht für Entwicklung von...
Musik passt gut dazu. Also, Milch und Zucker steht für Entwicklung von Talent-Acquisition und Talent-Ma...
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, ob man das richtig ausspricht.
Und Talent-Management-Lösung.
Ach, ne, die entwickeln so Recruiting-Portale oder sowas.
Unsere eigene Recruiting-Software.
150 helle Köpfe und 300 sprühende Hirnhirn...
Okay, die werben damit, dass sie extremely 5-Head sind.
Sprühen wir sorgen dafür, dass unsere Kunden die passenden IT-Lösungen für Recruiting-Prozesse
bekommen.
Im Spangar zwischen Standard und hochindividuell, menschlicher Intuition und künstlicher Intelligenz
raten Emotionen...
Ach du...
Alter was...
Okay, aber das sagt ja noch nix.
Das sagt ja noch nix.
300 Hirnhälften, also 150 Hirne, ja gut, 150 Hirne in 150 Köpfen, es sei denn jemand
hat mehr als eine, zwei Hirnhälften.
Okay, also, zeig mal her, äh, Frage Darkside, schickst du das, weil es besonders blöd ist,
was jetzt gleich kommt oder weil du dich dann bewerben willst.
Egal, sag's nicht, wir gucken's uns an.
Weil bis jetzt, bis jetzt sieht es ja vollkommen in Ordnung aus.
Halt, ein ziemlicher Cringe-Intro-Satz, aber gut, man...
muss halt irgendwas machen, wo die Leute vielleicht sich...
ja, wo man zumindest denkt, die Leute interessiert sich für.
Also, darum geht's.
Du bist ein Bind... als was entwerfen? Okay, Atmen.
Klassischer, klassischer Atmen.
Das, wo seit den letzten 10 Jahren die Leute erzählen, Administrator stirbt aus, finde ich lustig, ja.
Ich meine, klar, theoretisch ist es nicht mehr so, dass es, also es gibt halt noch viel mehr als nur Administration.
Früher hast du quasi geguckt, okay, IT-Infrastruktur, Admin, Admin, Admin, Admin, Admin, was anderes gab es da nicht.
Heute hast du halt schon noch ein bisschen mehr.
Du hast, du hast viele im DevOps-Bereich, Cloud-Engineering-Bereich, was, ach, was noch alles gibt.
Aber Admins gibt es immer noch. Also dieses ganze, oh Hilfe, bald gibt es keine Admins mehr, fand ich schon immer sehr merkwürdig, wie man auf die Idee kommt.
Weil ich mein, wer soll denn den Kram im Endeffekt betreiben? Auch in der Cloud. Ich mein, du hast auch eine Infrastruktur in der Cloud, die administriert werden muss.
Es ist ja nicht so, als nur, weil die Sachen jetzt auf einmal nicht beim eigenen AdSense stehen, sondern in der Cloud, dass es niemand mehr administrieren muss.
Auf so Ideen kommen nur Leute, die glaube ich da mit dem Betrieb von Systemen noch nie was zu tun hatten.
Ja, also ich mein, ist klar, dass du immer nur Admins brauchst.
Und das wirst du auch auf lange Zeit, auf längere Sicht wird das so bleiben.
Wirst du nicht, warum sich da was ändert.
Okay, also gucken wir uns das mal an.
Du bist Bindeglied zwischen unseren Entwicklern und dem Produktivsystem.
Ja gut, klingt ja schon mal sinnvoll für einen Admin.
Als technischer Admin fühlst du dich in Surferkellern und Rechen-
Ja, Kellern fühlen wir uns wohl, Leute.
Und Rechenzentren genauso, wie bei der täglichen Administration und Überwachung der Systeme.
Außerdem unterstützt du unsere Entwicklung bei der technischen Umsetzung von Kundenwünschen, Initiativen und so weiter.
Okay, blablabla. Also, zeig mal ja.
Installation, Konfiguration, Betreuung von Linux-Systemen.
Ja gut, das würde ich bei einem Systemadministrator Linux auch erwarten.
Okay, Rocky Linux. Das sind die ersten, die ich kenne, die live Rocky Linux benutzen.
Also, ihnen bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig, wenn sie was retten.
Okay, Alma vielleicht noch. Ich meine, ihnen bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig, wenn sie Redhead benutzen wollen, allerdings kein Redhead bezahlen wollen, außer Rocky oder Alma.
Gibt es eigentlich Scientific-Linux noch? Das war ja auch mal so ein Redhead-Clone.
Oracle-Linux, das blöde an Oracle-Linux ist, ich hab das schon öfters erzählt, du kannst
kein Oracle-Linux verwenden, kostenlos, wenn du Oracle-Datenbanken betreibst, weil Oracle-Datenbanken,
jetzt hört euch, hört euch das, also saugt das mal in euch auf, was Oracle da wieder
für einen Scheiß baut.
Also, Oracle hat eine Lizenzvereinbarung, dass wenn du einen Support-Vertrag hast für
eines ihrer Produkte und du möchtest ein anderes Produkt von ihnen einsetzen, dann
musst du dieses andere Produkt mindestens so lizenzieren wie das andere, was du schon
hast.
Das heißt im Endeffekt, du hast Oracle Datenbanken, du hast einen Supportvertrag für Oracle Datenbanken,
so und jetzt möchtest du Oracle Linux verwenden.
Kannst du normalerweise kostenlos verwenden.
Wenn du allerdings Oracle Datenbanken hast mit einem Supportvertrag, dann nicht, dann
dann musst du jede Oracle-Linux-Installation mindestens dem gleichen Support-Vertrag versichern
wie deine Oracle-Datenbanken.
Das heißt, du kannst normalerweise Oracle-Linux kostenlos benutzen, aber wenn du einen Support-Vertrag
mit Datenbanken hast, musst du halt einfach 55 Millionen bezahlen für deine anderen Sachen.
Oracle ist der letzte Drecksladen, was Lizenzen angeht.
Ich kann nicht verstehen, wie irgendjemand ernsthaft entscheidet, Oracle für irgendwas
zu benutzen.
Leute, ich muss das mal kurz rüber kopieren, die Stellanzeige ist mir zu grell, so ist
viel angenehmer.
Also, die benutzen Rocky Linux, ok, verstehe, leuchtet ja auch ein, wie gesagt, kannst ja
nur Rocky oder Alma noch sinnvoll benutzen, wenn du RedHat benutzen willst, aber kein
RedHat bezahlen willst.
Performance, Capacity und Availability Management, ok, alles klar, Anpassung und Erstellung von
Automatisierungsvorgängen, Ansible und Automatisierung, klingt auch sehr klassisch.
Systemadmin mäßig. Da ist der Übergang zwischen dem was man so unter Devops veranschlagt
und Admin eher fließend. Administration der VMware Cluster und SAN. Okay, die Läden die
ich kenne, die haben eigene Teams. Sowohl eigene Teams für SAN als auch eigene Teams
für VMware. Was auch oftmals daran liegt, dass halt Linux-Leute sich nicht zwangsläufig
mit Xan und VMware auskennen. Man muss nämlich mal fairness halber sagen, sowohl VMware als
auch Xan, wenn es eine größere Umgebung ist, das sind beides Wissenschaften für
sich. Also betreibt man eine komplexe VMware-Umgebung, betreibt man eine komplexe Xan-Storage-Infrastruktur,
da seid ihr eigentlich ausgelastet genug mit und könnt nicht nebenbei noch euch um
alle Linux-Systeme kümmern und umgedreht. Also, je nachdem, kommt immer drauf an, wie
umvergleicht das Ganze ist. Datensicherung, Backup und Recovery, ja, klingt sinnvoll,
zumindest, dass man sich Gedanken darüber macht, ob man jetzt das eigentliche Backup-System
auch administriert. Weiß man nicht, aber wahrscheinlich, wenn man auch vor allem Cluster
und SAN macht, kümmert man sich wahrscheinlich auch um das eigentliche Backup-System.
Okay, das bist du.
Als Netzwerkadministrator, ja wie jetzt?
Du denkst du wolltest Linux adminnen und kein Netzwerkadministrator?
Ich glaub das ist ein Copy-Paste-Fehler oder?
Als Netzwerkadministrator macht dir so schnell keiner was vor.
Du punktest, du punktest durch Erfahrungen und Neuigkeiten, kannst du in deinem Vorstellungsgespräch
gleich ansprechende Copy-Paste-Fehler entdeckt, wobei das macht keinen guten Eindruck gleich
zu sagen hier.
Aber man kann es ja auch nett ansprechen so, ich glaube ihr habt euch verschrieben.
Oder sie meinen das tatsächlich synonym, was aber eigentlich keinen Sinn ergibt.
Als Netzwerk-Administrator macht dir so schnell keiner was vor, du punktest durch Erfahrung
und Neugierde bis gewissenhaft...
Moment.
Gehen.
Bis gewissenhaft, man kann dir blind vertrauen, außerdem bist du ein absoluter Teamplayer
Und hast top, was? Ach und hast on top
Die Ausbildung, Erfahrung mit Linux idealerweise rettet, tiefgreifende Kenntnisse von Apache
PHP. Ich hab immer den Eindruck, diese Technologiesachen, die die da reinschreiben,
sind komplett random. So komplett, ja lasst uns da einfach mal ein bisschen was reinschreiben.
Apache? Ich meine, warum sollst du tiefgreifende Kenntnisse mit PHP haben?
Ich meine, du kannst einen yum install mysql und yum install php machen und vielleicht auch noch die ein oder andere Datenbankmigration laufen lassen, aber das reicht ja auch.
Aber das, gut, da muss man, da muss man aber nicht, klar, Silver, her damit, da muss man aber nicht so viel drauf geben, wie gesagt, oftmals wird das erstellt von irgendwelchen Personalleuten, die ein paar Begriffe noch hingeschmissen bekommen von der Technik und dann irgendwie so ein Best-of draus bauen.
Muss man nicht so viel drauf geben, es ist durchaus okay, wenn das da so drinsteht.
Ich mein, kann ja auch durchaus sein, dass sie das hier als ihren, wie man so schön sagt heutzutage, Technologie-Stack benutzen.
Wobei gerade die Apache-PAP-Kombi schon sehr, sehr oldschool ist.
Und also, die Apache-PAP-MySQL-Kombi schon sehr oldschool ist.
Ich mein, nicht, dass es nicht funktionieren würde oder so, aber...
Elasticsearch und Tomcat Setups
Verständnis von TCP IP Netzwerktechnik, NAT, VPN oder IPsec, Firewalls sowie Docker, Kubernetes, ach Kubernetes auch noch, okay
Ja gut, wie gesagt, ich gehe davon aus, diese Stellenanzeige ist halt mal wieder entstanden
Die Personalabteilung hat es am Ende geschrieben, die haben keine Ahnung von diesen Sachen, die da drinnen stehen
Und die Teams oder das Team, was jemand braucht, hat halt ein paar Begriffe hingeschmissen und dann kommt dann halt sowas raus.
Aber ein bisschen Erfahrung damit ist ja heutzutage auch nicht zu viel verlangt, weil ganz im Ernst, ich finde es zwar ein bisschen hart,
dass du dich um quasi komplette VMware-Infrastruktur sahen und um die Leadings-Infrastruktur kümmern sollst,
aber man weiß ja nicht, wie groß das ist.
Ich meine, vielleicht meinen die ja auch mit sahen im Endeffekt eine Storage-Kiste, wo du dich alle Schaltjahre mal drauf einloggen musst
Und Forever Cluster irgendwie, ähm, drei Kisten irgendwie in ein paar Racks stehen, so, also.
Ja.
Virtualisierungstechnik? Know-how! Aha, Nagios-Stelz sehe ich hier.
Okay, es war mal Nagios, es ist mittlerweile, glaube ich, kein Nagios mehr.
mehr. Spacewar! Gibt's das überhaupt noch? Ich dachte, das heißt jetzt Satellite, oder?
Das ist ein Webinterface für Red Hat-basierte Distributionen, wo man z.B. sagt, ja, was macht
man über Satellite? Kann man seine Systeme drin registrieren und Skripts laufen lassen und sowas?
Also, ich kenn keinen, der das noch ernsthaft benutzt. Also bei mir auf der aktuellen Arbeit
gibt es irgendwo auch noch, irgendwo in den Untiefen,
nen Red Hat Satellite, aber ich glaub so wirklich machen tut damit keiner was.
Was sie stellen beschreiben, Linux Server Administra- äh nee, Systemadministrator Linux.
Okay, dann sollst du noch ein bisschen Ahnung von Ansible haben, vollkommen okay in der heutigen Zeit.
Ansible ist eigentlich so das Tool schlechthin,
zur Automatisierung, beziehungsweise zum Einstieg in Infrastructure as Code, wie das die coolen Leute nennen.
Allerdings im Cloud-Umfeld ist es dann tatsächlich eher Terraform und Ansible ist halt das verbreitetste
und ich würde auch sagen, meiner, zumindest meiner persönlichen Meinung nach, das beste
Tool für solche Geschichten, was es aktuell gibt, gerade für klassische Linux-Server-Konfigurationen.
Ansible hat ein paar Negativpunkte, die so Sachen wie beispielsweise Puppet besser können,
aber dafür kann Ansible alles andere besser.
Also Puppet kann zum Beispiel schöne, schöne Try-Runs, wo man sieht, was passieren würde, dafür ist Ansible so viel angenehmer zu programmieren.
Beziehungsweise, kann man das Programmieren nennen? Ja, ich nenn's mal Programmieren.
Ähm, als Puppet. Meiner Meinung nach.
So, Docker auch okay, HA-Proxy auch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Pacemaker Chorusing, boah, das hab ich ja schon lange nicht mal in der Stellenanzeige gelesen.
Zur Erklärung, also wer mal Linux Cluster gebaut hat von Hand, der hat das wahrscheinlich mit Pacemaker und Corosync gemacht.
Das ist in letzter Zeit weniger angesagt als noch vor 15 Jahren.
Also die Kombi habe ich schon lange lange nicht mehr gelesen.
Ich bin mir aus dem Kopf gar nicht mehr sicher, was für was zuständig ist.
Ich glaube, Pacemaker ist für die Keep-Alive-Geschichte zuständig, so mit IP-Schwenken und sonst was.
Und für was war kochen sind noch mal zuständig ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau
Ich kenne beides aber schon ewig nicht mehr von eben von hand aufgesetzt und benutzt
Die kippe live kippe live ist das zum umschwenken von von alpes pacemaker ist die geschichte mit
Erkennen ob der note ab oder da ich weiß es aus dem kopf nicht mehr
Ich weiß nicht, es ist zu lange her.
Also ohne Scheiß, die Sachen in Kombi, das habe ich zuletzt vor 10 Jahren verwendet.
So.
IPTables Shorewall.
Ist das nicht irgendein Standalone-Linux-Distro?
Ach ne, das ist irgendein Konfigurationstool.
Kennt man das?
Release-Notes von 2020.
Okay, auch nicht sonderlich aktualisiert.
Okay.
nicht sonderlich aktuell. Was ist das? Ist das irgendein Management-Interface oder Monkathos?
Ist das ein bisschen so ein Linux-Server-Config-Webinterface? Die Dinger, die eigentlich
keiner verwendet wenn er noch irgendwie halbwegs bei verstanden ist sieht ja top
aktuell aus
sehr gut warum nicht so unser system erwünscht sehr gutes deutsch c1 gute
Englisch kennen, ist B2. Keine Ahnung, das sind irgendwelche Stufen, wie flüssig man redet.
Ja, klingt doch in Ordnung. Ist doch alles, ist doch passend. Ich meine, ich kann an allem
irgendwie rummäckern, aber im Großen und Ganzen klingt das doch eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich muss aber sagen, es ist jetzt auch nichts, was mich vom Hocker haut, wo ich denken würde,
oh ja, da muss ich mich jetzt unbedingt bewerben. Ich suche ja eh nichts Neues.
Sieht sehr 0815 aus, kann aber durchaus was taugen. Ich glaube, dazu muss man den Laden kennen.
Ja, wie gesagt, das habe ich ja schon geschickt.
Pogu, ich bin mittlerweile nicht bei E3-Status Rust, ich bin bei Bumblebee-Status, ist das
hier.
Hattet ihr mal eine Erfahrung bei einem Dienstleister zu arbeiten, kann ich es empfehlen.
In der modernen IT Welt sind alles Dienstleister.
Das geht dann so weit, dass in einem Team gesprochen wird, das ist unser Kunde.
Das ist sowas, da stehen die ganzen Manager und Businessleute irgendwie drauf.
Du sagst, du darfst da nicht mehr sagen, ey, die Entwickler wollen wieder komisches Zeug, das ist ja Standard, so ein bisschen Gezanke zwischen Entwicklung und Admins ist ja eigentlich normal, ja.
Die Admins sagen, Entwickler programmieren nur Scheiß und die Entwickler sagen, alter, warum machen die das alles immer so kompliziert?
Das ist normal, ein bisschen, ja.
Zumindest stehen die ganzen Manager drauf, die wollen, dass man nicht sagt, ey, die Entwickler wollen wieder komisches Zeug.
Die wollen sagen, unser Kunde aus der Entwicklung möchte das und das und so.
Halte ich mich aber immer nicht dran.
Ich meine, ganz ehrlich, gut, bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber ist es auch nicht so extrem.
So dieses, ja wir reden jetzt nur noch von Kunden, wir reden jetzt nicht mehr von irgendwie anderer Abteilung, das sind alles unsere Kunden.
Das ist irgendeiner, der unbedingt Italspeak einführen will, aber mit der Realität nichts zu tun hat.
Ey, ähm.
Also ja, ich kann dir aber auch sagen, wie es ist, bei einem Dienstleister zu arbeiten.
Warum habe ich das erste eigentlich jetzt erzählt? Achso, ja, weil ja mittlerweile alles nur noch Dienstleister sind, so laut Management-Gehirnspinzen.
Ja, ich kann dir erzählen, wie es ist, bei einem Dienstleister zu arbeiten, weil ich habe meine Ausbildung bei einem Internetprovider beziehungsweise bei einem Dienstleister für
Netzwerkservices und Virtualisierungsservices und Geschiss gemacht, aber damals gab es noch keine Azure Cloud und sowas.
Tja, und was kann ich dir sagen? Also ich kann dir sagen, der Laden war scheiße, das lag aber nicht daran, weil es ein Dienstleister war.
Das lag daran, weil der Scheiße geführt war.
Hab ich ja genug Videos drüber gemacht, dass ich auf die nicht so gut zu sprechen war, muss man sagen, weil der Laden ist mittlerweile pleite.
Ansonsten war es für mich eigentlich nur von Vorteil, dass es ein Dienstleister war, bei dem ich gearbeitet habe, weil die haben mich verschachert nach Frankfurt.
Und, ähm, also nicht, es war keine Arbeit, äh, wie heißt das, keine, keine, ähm, Vermittlungsbude.
Ja, die haben uns, die haben uns quasi dorthin verkauft von, also wir waren angestellt beim Provider und die haben halt das AdSense-Management,
das Rechenzentrums-Management von dieser, von der Bank in Frankfurt damals gemacht.
Deswegen war ich halt dann dort in Frankfurt und deswegen konnte ich auch direkt bei der Bank in Frankfurt anfangen, als ich gekündigt habe beim Provider damals.
Die kannten mich alle schon, ich kannte die auch schon.
Ich hab gesagt, Jungs, ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf meinen aktuellen Arbeitgeber, kann ich nicht direkt bei euch anfangen.
Ich mach auch genau das gleiche weiter.
Dann haben die gesagt, Max, weißt du was, komm zu uns, kriegst sogar mehr Geld und schick mal die Kündigung ab.
Dann bin ich zu denen gekommen, hab mehr Geld gekriegt und hab die Kündigung abgeschickt.
Ich komme aus Frankfurt. Doch, doch, doch. Naja, nicht direkt aus Frankfurt, aber ziemlich nah an Frankfurt dran.
Also, ich bin geboren in Offenbach, ich wohne in Hanau und ich arbeite in Frankfurt. Das ist alles die gleiche Ecke.
Da würde ich mich ja nicht drauf verlassen, nachts.
Ey, die Templates, die der Dienstleister generiert hat, sind komplett abartig, weil die haben die Templates nicht selbst gebaut,
die haben die Templates selbst wiederum generiert mit irgendeinem Generator-Script.
Die sehen aus wie Sau. Kannste blickste nicht durch.
Ja, kann man ja nicht, weil der Hersteller das updatet und neu liefert. Also man kann es ja noch nicht mal fixen.
Der Hersteller muss das fixen.
Was hältst du eigentlich von einem Thinkpad T480 für den...
Ich weiß nicht, was da drin ist, aber die Thinkpads kann man in der Regel für...
Für Daily Linux ist das admin-business gut empfehlen.
Da kannst du dir entweder ein Arch-Linux draufhauen, oder wenn's ein bisschen was klassischeres sein soll, kannst du dir auch ein Mint, Ubuntu oder meinetwegen auch ein Suso oder irgendwas draufhauen, was offiziell bei euch auf der Arbeit benutzt werden darf.
Die Dinger funktionieren meistens komplett ohne jegliche Probleme unter Linux.
Also ich hatte jahrelang beim alten Arbeitgeber nur IBM Notebooks
und halt später Lenovo Notebooks.
Ja, wie gesagt, bei dem Dienstleister, wo wir aktuell die Installer davon bekommen,
die Packages lässt sich auch nichts installieren.
Zabix!
Wie sprichst
du das aus?
Bist du eher im Lager Zabix oder
eher Zabix?
Das sind ja glaube ich
Weißrussen oder so, die Zabix-Leute.
Oh ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Oh je, oh je. Jetzt werden sie
bestimmt stinkig, wenn sie das gehört haben.
Ne, Litauer sind das glaube ich, Litauer.
Die Zabix-Hersteller. Also Zabix ist
Das ist so ne Monitoring, ein Enterprise Class Open Source Network Monitor, was auch immer sie selbst sagen, Solution wahrscheinlich, also Monitoring System.
Und wenn man sich Videos von denen anguckt, die sprechen es immer Zabbix aus, aber teilweise so richtig Zabbix.
Zabbix, ich hab ein Video gesehen von einer, die hat irgendwie die neue Zabbix-Version gezeigt
und hat gesagt, the new Zabbix
und ich konnte mir das Video nicht angucken, wegen der Aussprache von Zabbix, alter
Z-Z-Z-Zabbix
und ich dachte, oh, ich muss ausmachen
Die sprechen in ihren Zappics, spricht in ihren eigenen Youtube-Videos das so eklig aus.
Und das sollte man eigentlich denken, die wissen was sie machen.
Habt ihr das als Monitoring?
Nee.
Also wir haben beim neuen Arbeitgeber nicht, beim alten Arbeitgeber hatten wir Zabbix als
Monitoring jahrelang.
Das wurde aber immer weiter out gefacet.
Achja, da gibt es auch eine lustige Geschichte, die ich jetzt noch gehört habe und zwar,
Sie hatten lange Zeit Sub-X beim alten Arbeitgeber zum Überwachen, von Netzwerkgeräten, von Servern, von allem, von Infrastruktur, ja?
Und das wurde jetzt nach und nach ersetzt, weil sie haben ein eigenes Team aufgemacht, was übrigens eine sehr gute Entscheidung war, auch jetzt im Nachhinein betrachtet.
Sie haben beim alten Arbeitgeber, hatten sie ein neues Team aufgemacht, die sich nur um Monitoringbelange kümmern soll.
Und das ist ja auch wirklich ein komplexes Thema, wo man durchaus mal vier, fünf Leute hinorten kann, die sich damit beschäftigen.
Und das wurde nach und nach quasi dann out gefacet bei uns, der Zubbix
und ersetzt durch eine Mischung aus Prometheus, Grafana und
ähm, tja, Alert Manager und halt automatischem irgendwie Ticket-Ticket-Generieren daraus
war eigentlich nicht verkehrt, wie sie das gemacht haben.
Hatte seine Vorteile, also hatte viele Vorteile gegenüber Zubbix, gerade was Langzeitmetrixspeicherung angeht,
Hatte aber auch ein bisschen seine Nachteile halt, dass es viel gestückelter ist als TabX.
TabX ist halt so eine komplett zusammenhängende Monitoring-Lösung.
Zumindest habe ich jetzt folgendes gehört von meinem alten Arbeitgeber.
Jetzt, nachdem Sie TabX abgeschafft haben, haben Sie einen neuen Netzwerkdienstleister
und der möchte nur mit TabX arbeiten.
Und wenn wir keinen eigenen TabX haben, wo wir den Zugriff drauf geben könnten,
dann bauen Sie Ihren eigenen TabX auf und rechnen uns das ab.
Ist auch geil, oder? Ja, good luck, have fun, alles zu outsourcen.
Erst abgeschafft und jetzt gibt's wieder Zabex.
Hast du Erfahrung mit kleinen Server-Backups im Enterprise-Umfeld?
Als Client ja, als Admin nicht. Also ich kenne eigentlich bloß Tivoli.
Und das ist nix, was ich freiwillig benutzen würde.
Die reden die ganze Zeit noch von Bandlaufwerken und sowas in dem Kontext.
Also ich kenne im Enterprise Umfeld nur Tivoli, was Backups angeht.
Also für so wirklich komplett Backups von Systemen und sowas.
VM ist ja eher was für VMs.
Wobei ne, nicht nur, kannst theoretisch auch alles mögliche mit machen.
VM kenne ich aber nur aus dem VMware Umfeld.
Also ich, im Enterprise Umfeld kenne ich tatsächlich nur Tivoli,
wo das überall eingesetzt wurde. Also ich kenne das von drei Arbeitgebern jetzt.
Scheinen im Enterprise-Umfeld beliebt zu sein, gerade wenn es in der Finanzbranche
ist und die genug Geld haben. Aber alles was ich davon gesehen habe bisher ist ekelig.
Die hätten 299 hinschreiben müssen, du meinst für die Path Rehat Leute.
Low IQ checkt aus.
Das ist doch ein PDF.
Traue ich mich hier ein PDF aufzumachen?
Ja, okay.
Krass.
Microsoft Word 2022.
Was du gepostet hast, ist das was,
wo du dich bewerben willst oder was besonders blöd ist oder was ist der Hintergrund warum du das gepostet hast also nur da ich so ein
bisschen weiß
Ich mag sie mal doof, ok, gucken wir uns gleich an, dachte man, ne, also man kann als
Webserver ja prinzipiell nehmen was man will, also es ist egal ob das patchy ist, NGINX, ich persönlich mag NGINX
wobei es halt
vermehrt so ist heutzutage
dass die Anwendung eigentlich selbst ihren Webserver mitbringt und man den
eigentlichen Webserver davor entweder gar nicht mehr hat, weil man ein extra
Loadbalancer davor hat bzw. Reverse Proxy davor hat oder aber auf dem
Rechner, also auf dem Server selbst noch mal vorgelagert ein Webserver ist, der
allerdings auch nichts anderes als Zertifikatshandling und Reverse Proxy
macht. Also die meisten Anwendungen bringen heute eigentlich ihren Webserver mit.
Ich würde sagen die meisten Anwendungen außer php
Oder ich kenne mich zu schlecht mit php aus
Ich würde sagen die meisten Anwendungen beziehungsweise die meisten
Frameworks bringen den Webserver mit außer php
Also Ruby und Rails bringt schon immer mit
Springboot ist ein eigener Webserver, .NET bringt ihren eigenen Webserver mit
Node.js bringt seinen eigenen Web-Server mit, Go bringt seinen eigenen Web-Server mit, also
Go Backends bringt seinen eigenen Web-Server mit, also eigentlich bringt nahezu alles seinen
eigenen Web-Server mit, das heißt im Endeffekt startest du die Anwendung halt mit, du startest
einfach nur die Anwendung, so, und dann lauscht die an einem Port und spricht HTTP, fertig,
und das expostest du ja normalerweise nicht direkt ins Internet, sondern du hast halt
in irgendeiner Art und Weise ein Loadbalancer-Reverse-Proxy davor, der zum Beispiel SSL-Zertifikatshandling
macht und wo du die Backends rausnehmen kannst, wenn eines kaputt ist oder im besten Fall
sogar automatisch rausgenommen wird oder das Loadbalancing entscheidet anhand von wie viele
Connections die Backends haben, wie ausgelassene die Backends sind und sowas, wie es verteilt
wird.
Also meistens hast du da eh noch was davor.
Ja, und das kann durchaus ein NGINX sein, es kann auch eine HA-Proxy sein oder irgendwas.
Aber Apache sieht man halt da an der Stelle tatsächlich dann relativ wenig.
Einfach aus dem Grund, weil Apache halt so ein riesen komplexes Ding ist. Klar, NGINX auch, aber ich finde die Minimal-NGINX-Config
irgendwie eingänglicher als Apache. Ich persönlich muss ja sagen, für kleine Sachen schwöre ich auf Kadi als Web-Server.
weil simpler kann die konfiguration echt nicht mehr werden
guckt mal ihr müsst euch ihr müsst euch mal die die example konfig angucken was
sie irgendwie hier nicht haben
wie blöd möchte man eine startseite machen also ich meine ja das ist alles
aber die meisten Leute benutzen es für SSL Handling. Also du brauchst... using caddy file,
okay. Ja, die Beispiele sind ein bisschen blöd, aber du brauchst meistens nur zwei,
drei Zeilen, dann hast du einen fertig aufgesetzten Reverse Proxy,
der für dich HTTPS, Zertifikatshandling und sowas macht.
Ob das nicht so toll skaliert oder nicht, kann ich jetzt nicht beurteilen.
Ich würde mal sagen, ob das skaliert oder nicht, wird nicht zwangsläufig an PHP oder MySQL liegen,
sondern an dem, wie du deine Anwendungen strukturierst.
Also du wirst MySQL denke ich halbwegs gescheit skalieren können.
Gehe ich jetzt einfach mal von aus.
Wie gesagt, ihr wisst, dass ich nicht der allergrößte Datenbank-Checker bin,
aber ich kenne zum Beispiel noch die klassische Variante, wie man früher Datenbanken skaliert hat,
skaliert hat, quasi ein Node mit Write-Access und ganz viele quasi Read-Only-Nodes, was für die meisten Anwendungen vollkommen okay war.
Das war halt gleichzeitig die Art und Weise, wie man Datenbanken skaliert hat, beziehungsweise auch Datenbanken ein bisschen hochverfügbar gemacht hat.
Mit neueren Datenbanken, die man, so wie Cassandra DB und sowas, die man verteilen kann in der Cloud, ist es natürlich noch cooler.
Aber ich denke, man kann MySQL auch sinnig skalieren.
PAP, klar, hängt ein bisschen davon ab, wie man das ganze programmiert, wenn man alles in eine Anwendung reinhaut,
die nicht gescheit mehrfach gestartet werden kann, dann macht es sicherlich Probleme, wenn man das ein bisschen aufsplittet.
Also ich denke, im Endeffekt hängt es nach wie vor nicht so sehr an der Technologiekombination.
Wenn es jetzt, auch wenn diese Kombi für mich jetzt nicht super krasses Skalieren schreit, aber in Maßen lässt sich das immer noch ganz gut skalieren, wenn man es gescheit macht.
Also ich würde nicht sagen, das geht nicht, aber es muss gescheit gemacht sein, was so ziemlich auf jede Anwendung eigentlich zutrifft.
Ist egal, ob das jetzt eine Node.js, eine Go oder eine .NET Anwendung ist.
Das muss so gebaut sein, dass sich es gut skalieren lässt.
Und man kann man kann jetzt auch nicht das war oft genug betonen viele sachen müssten gar nicht bis zum umkippen skaliert werden können
Also es ist es ist doch wirklich selten so dass man die anforderung hat
Quasi von fünf instanzen auf 5000 rauf und runter skalieren zu können dynamisch
So on the fly mehrfach am tag und sowas in der richtung es ist ja eigentlich
Also, wenn man jetzt nicht gerade Amazon ist und das Frontend bei irgendwie so unterschiedlichen Tageszeiten und Länder, wo die Leute einkaufen.
Also, ganz ehrlich, das was ich gesehen habe bisher, auch im Business Enterprise Finanzbranche Umfeld, wie das da mit Skalierung gehandhabt wird, ist doch recht...
Sag mal konservativ, da stellst du mal ein bei einem Kubernetes Cluster, ja, wenn du
Bock hast, kannst du auch bis zu 5 Nodes hochziehen und wenn du Bock hast, kannst du auch bis
zu, keine Ahnung, 10 Replikas starten davon, aber im Großen und Ganzen so super dynamisch
Skalierte Anwendungen, wo täglich mehrfach, also, hab ich persönlich so selten erlebt, also
Deswegen Schlussfolger ich da draus jetzt einfach auch mal, dass das seltener vorkommt, als man vielleicht in irgendwelchen Konferenztalks sieht
Ich mein, wann hast du so ein, wann hast du so einen Fall, ja?
Okay, stellt euch vor, ihr betreibt einen Shop und PewDiePie gibt euch unverhofftenen Shoutout für euren Shop, was auch immer, ja?
Und ihr habt normalerweise 500 User irgendwie, keine Ahnung, in der Stunde und dann habt ihr auf einmal 5 Millionen.
Dann wäre es ganz gut, wenn euer Shop skalieren könnte. Das kommt aber wahrscheinlich recht selten vor.
Und man kann ja auch seine Anwendung skalieren auf klassische Art und Weise.
Also man muss ja nicht alles in 1000 Microservices aufspalten oder irgendwelche cloudfähigen Datenbanken nehmen,
über die Welt verteilt und irgendwie super krasse Sperenzien da machen.
Bis zum gewissen Maße kann man natürlich auch sehr schön skalieren mit, wir machen einfach fettere Hardware hin.
Was eventuell sogar gar nicht so blöde Idee sein kann, weil es oftmals einfacher ist,
was zu starten oder halt ein Projekt anzufangen, wenn man nicht
von Anfang an erst mal alles in 1000 Microservices
aufsplittet oder guckt, wie können wir das jetzt mit irgendeiner super modernen
Cloud-Native-Datenbank-Lösung machen, dass das alles schön skaliert und wo
pappen wir noch irgendwelche Memory-Caches hin, wo pappen wir noch irgendwelche
Message-Queues hin, sondern man baut einfach eine klassische Anwendung, die
das macht, was gemacht werden soll. Einfach weil es sich viel schneller
entwickeln lässt und dann startet man, guckt ob das überhaupt irgendjemand
benutzen will und fängt an und lässt seine Leute ein bisschen Werbung für
machen und gerade am Anfang kann man auch noch wunderbar skalieren mit lasst uns
mal eine fettere Kiste hinstellen, lasst uns mal zwei fette Kisten hinstellen,
lasst uns mal unseren Datenbank Cluster erweitern.
Der Trend geht auch wieder weg von Microservices, ja das liegt aber daran,
weil die Leute immer allem hinterher rennen, was Amazon oder irgendwelche
tollen Konferenz-Talk-Leute und Hype-Leute erzählen. Der Trend geht jetzt wieder weg
von Microservices, zumindest im Kopf der Leute, weil Amazon letztens einen Blog-Artikel rausgehauen
hat, dass sie selber für ihr Video-Prime-Streaming weniger Microservices verwenden. Die hatten
da aber auch so ein übertrieben abgedrehtes Microservices-Konstrukt, wo ich mir gedacht
habe, Alter, da hättet ihr auch selbst auf die Idee kommen können, dass es keine gute
Idee ist, quasi gefühlt für jeden Video-Frame einen eigenen Container zu starten.
Die haben ja wirklich, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob sie für jeden Video-Frame einen eigenen
Container gestartet haben, aber sie haben für jeden Videostream einen eigenen Container
gestartet und sowas.
Ganz furchtbar abgedrehtes Zeug, wo man sich eigentlich beim Blick auf die Architektur
von Anfang an denken konnte, also ob das jetzt so eine schlaue Sache ist, fraglich.
Gut, wenn ich das gesehen hätte und hätte mir gedacht, das ist eine blöde Idee, nächste
was ich mir gedacht hätte, ist okay, das ist Amazon, die werden schon wissen, was sie machen,
aber da sind wir wieder beim Punkt, auch Amazon kocht nur mit Wasser.
Aber für jeden Videostream und teilweise eigene Frames, eigene Container starten, ja,
natürlich, das skaliert richtig krass, aber da hast du ja so viel Overhead vom ganzen Container starten
und Content kopieren und sonst was, was auch keine allzu schlaue Idee ist.
Man muss, ganz ehrlich, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, man muss einfach gucken, dass das unterm Strich
für den Anwendungsfall, den man hat, passt und am besten ist, man macht sich vorher ein bisschen
Gedanken drüber, wie man das, wie man das Ganze so aufbaut, anstatt irgendwelche Hype-Technologien
zu verwenden, nur weil das irgendwie auf irgendeiner Konferenz cool aussah oder weil Microsoft da oder
oder Amazon oder wer auch immer irgendein Blog-Eintrag drüber verfasst hat. Ja, das ist genauso wie,
soll man Sachen in Kubernetes laufen lassen oder nicht? Also ich würde sagen, ja, es ist eine gute
Idee prinzipiell wenn es halt zur Anwendung passt und dem was man machen
will. Wenn man einen Webshop betreiben will für was weiß ich für die Oma die
ab und zu mal ein paar selbst gestrickte Sachen verkauft dann muss das nicht auf
ein kubernetes cluster laufen. Es muss halt einfach Sinn
machen für die Anwendung oder für die Anwendungen oder für die
Die Services müsste man dann eigentlich sagen, die man anbieten will.
Es muss halt einfach passen.
Und die Anwendungen müssen halt auch darauf ausgelegt sein.
Es bringt halt nix, wenn du jetzt eine Anwendung baust,
die eigentlich gar nicht darauf ausgelegt ist, dass sie mehrfach gestartet werden kann.
Dann musst du die auch nicht auf Kubernetes laufen lassen.
Wenn du jetzt eine Anwendung hast, die laufen irgendwelche Datenbanklogs,
Filesystem-Logs oder gar Sachen auf Fileshares schreibt und liest und loggt und sonst was
oder ganz, weißt du, so Dinger, die halt teilweise Oldschool-Anwendungen machen, da musst du
dir nicht den Kubernetes-Cluster hauen, weil es bringt dir nix, wenn du die Anwendung dreifach
im Kubernetes-Cluster laufen lässt, wenn das Ding quasi alle externe Ressourcen, wo
es darauf zugreift, immer exklusiv loggen muss.
Das hat überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Und es macht auch keinen Sinn, wenn du sie nicht skalieren können möchtest.
Wenn du einfach nur sagst, ey ich will 3 Backend Instanzen haben, dann stell dir 3 VMs hin.
Und gut, da bist du sogar in der Cloud noch wahrscheinlich billiger bei als mit dem Kubernetes Cluster.
Nun ja, was sagst du zu Kubernetes und Datenbank? Ich mag die Kombination nicht.
Ich hab letztens ein Video geguckt von jemand auf YouTube, der wollte, der wollte einem erzählen, dass Kubernetes der beste Weg ist, in der Cloud Datenbanken laufen zu lassen.
Ich bin, zumindest bis jetzt noch, vielleicht werde ich ja mal irgendwie noch überzeugt davon, ich bin bis jetzt der Meinung, dass es in der Regel keine allzu schlaue Idee ist, klassische, relationale Datenbanken in Kubernetes laufen zu lassen.
Es mag mit so Sachen wie Cassandra DB und solchen Sachen vielleicht anders aussehen, da muss ich aber dazu sagen, da habe ich jetzt nicht so viel praktische Erfahrung mit.
Aber ich meine, Cassandra ist immerhin so eine Datenbank, die eben darauf ausgelegt ist, quasi kontinentweit, weltweit in der Cloud verteilt zu werden und synchron zu bleiben.
Also das würde sich eher dafür eignen.
Für klassische, relationale Datenbanken in Kubernetes, ich persönlich bin da überhaupt kein Fan von,
du hast, du hast ja damit, also ich finde, du hast damit nichts gewonnen,
weil das Problem, wie cluster ich die Datenbanken, hast du immer noch.
Also, so wie du, also, nur weil du jetzt einen Kubernetes-Cluster hast und da drinnen drei Postgres laufen lassen kannst,
heißt das noch lange nicht, dass die sich irgendwie miteinander unterhalten,
also einen Postgres-Cluster musst du nach wie vor bauen.
Nur, dass du da noch Kobanedis drunter hast.
Ja, und um deine Anwendung musst du dir auch Gedanken machen.
Also im Endeffekt.
Und du hast halt auch weitere Probleme mit, wo lasse ich Migrations laufen, wie mache
ich das, wenn ich meinen Cluster upgrade, wie mache ich das, wenn ich meine Anwendung
Rolling Updates mache, dass das mit dem Schema passt und sowas.
Gut, das hast du auch, wenn das extern läuft.
Ja, also ich bin der Meinung, dass Datenbanken in Kobanedis oft mal, wenn man nicht weiß
was man macht. Ja, vielleicht weiß ich einfach nur nicht, was ich mache. Ich halte das für keine allzu gute Idee, denn es gibt eine
viel bessere Alternative,
gerade wenn man den Kubernetes Cluster in der Cloud betreibt, was man nach Möglichkeit machen sollte, weil Kubernetes
Selbstmanagen ist eigentlich so ein Ding,
da hast du über kurz oder lang Probleme.
Ja, aus
Aus unterschiedlichsten Gründen, weil bei Kubanetes der Fehler bzw. die Probleme oftmals im Detail stecken.
Kubanetes an selbst ist ja nicht das, was das kompliziert ist, das ganze Ökosystem drumherum und die tausend Sachen, die man beachten muss und das rausfinden, wie ist jetzt für mich der beste Weg, was zu machen.
Das ist ja eigentlich das Komplizierte.
Und deswegen sollte man nach Möglichkeit eh einen Managed Kubanetes benutzen.
Und wenn man ein Managed-Kopernetnis nutzt, dann ist die Chance, dass der Cloud-Anbieter, bei dem man ist, eine Managed-Datenbank anbietet, enorm hoch.
Es bieten eigentlich alle, die mir so einfallen, Managed-Datenbanken an.
Azure, Google, Microsoft, ähm, ne Quatsch.
Amazon, Google, Microsoft bieten Managed-Datenbanken an.
DigitalOcean bietet Datenbanken an.
Wenn du jetzt natürlich ein bisschen runtergehst und sagst, hey, gucken wir mal bei einfachen Hosting-Providern,
Zum Beispiel Hetzner, die bieten keine Managed Datenbanken an, aber Hetzner bietet auch keinen Managed Kubernetes an.
Bei Hetzner kannst du dir mit ein paar Terraform-Scripts von GitHub relativ einfach einen Kubernetes-Cluster bauen lassen.
Das ist dann aber kein Managed Kubernetes-Cluster, da musst du dich selbst drum kümmern.
Du musst dich um deine Control-Nodes selbst kümmern, du musst dich um deine Worker-Nodes selbst kümmern.
Also, ja, das ist eigentlich nur eine Installer-Hilfe.
Deswegen Datenbanken, Datenbankenkuba, ne das bin ich kein Fan von, weil die einfachste Variante ist, einfach die Datenbanken benutzen, die der jeweilige Cloud-Anbieter zur Verfügung stellt und damit hat man dann überhaupt keine Probleme.
Kostet halt meistens ein bisschen mehr als den Kram komplett selbst zu betreiben, weil, ja gut, die wollen auch was verdienen, aber die kümmern sich halt auch drum, dass das ordentlich geclustert ist, ordentlich gemanagt wird, ordentlich geupdatet wird, sodass du möglichst wenig von mitkriegst.
7LQRS Dankeschön für den Sub. Poggers Kekstose hat Glück gehabt. 420. Pog Subscription. Noch
einer. TheOrzelot hat es eingekriegt. Danke für die zwei Subs. Ja also so seh ich das.
Ja zum Thema skalieren und Datenbanken in der Cloud und solche Geschichten.
Oh man, ich bin ja übelst weit hinten dran.
Das ist SAP, oder?
SAP ist immer Pains Champ.
Ja, IPTables juckt doch eh keinen so wirklich, äh nicht IPTables, IPv6 juckt doch eh im Enterprise-Umfeld
keinen wirklich.
Überlegt euch mal, ich glaub selbst riesen Seiten wie Amazon sind nicht mal über IPv6
erreichbar.
Ist Twitch mittlerweile über IPv6 eigentlich erreichbar?
Das nennt niemand ernst, das ist so, IPv6 ist seit 15 Jahren sich am durchsetzen.
die einzigen die das abfuckt aktuell sind leute die kein dual stack mehr
bekommen bei vodafone zum beispiel die sind gefickt
wobei die müssen halt über so einen doofen dsli tunnel was extrem sagt
ansonsten ihr kennt meine meinung was was was um ipv6 sich durchsetzen angeht
Also, das was ich mir dazu denke ist folgendes, ich glaube nicht, dass wir den Tag erleben
werden, dass alles was jetzt über IPv4 erreichbar ist, über IPv6 erreichbar sein wird.
Was ich mir persönlich vorstellen könnte, und ja wie wahrscheinlich das ist, müsste
man mal gucken.
Aber was ich mir persönlich vorstellen könnte ist, dass wenn Google, Microsoft, Amazon und wenn die alle
echt Probleme bekommen mit IPv4 und IPv6 benötigen würden,
dass sie sich was eigenes ausdenken.
Ich weiß, das ist nicht so einfach, wie es sich jetzt anhört.
Du kannst nicht einfach mal ein Layer 3 Protokoll easy ersetzen.
Ja, das muss an sehr vielen Stellen unterstützt werden, dass das funktioniert, vom Client über deine Anwendungen, von den ganzen Implementierungen für alle Betriebssysteme und sonst was.
Deswegen hab ich ja persönlich die Vermutung, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie sticherlich das ist und wie wahrscheinlich das ist und wie wirklich umsetzbar das ist.
hab ich ein bisschen, tu ich mir ein bisschen schwer, aber man hat's, man hat's gesehen, dass, wenn die großen
IT-Unternehmen dieser Welt, ja, von Microsoft, Facebook, sonst was, wenn die anfangen gemeinsame Sache zu machen
oder an irgendwelchen gemeinsamen Sachen mitzuwirken, guckt euch mal Browser,
Browser-Entwicklung an zum Beispiel, die letzten Jahre, gut, das ist ja im Prinzip,
Browser-Entwicklung, okay, es gibt ja eigentlich nur zwei Browser, es gibt, es gibt Firefox und es gibt Chrome,
Die ziehen ungefähr am gleichen Strang und es gibt noch, ich hab gehört, es gibt auch noch sowas wie WebKit, also quasi Safari, die aber hoffnungslos quasi veraltet sind, so wie früher der Internet Explorer.
Okay, nicht so krass wie früher der Internet Explorer, aber wenn man sich mal die Features anguckt, die Chrome und Firefox unterstützen versus die Features, die Safari unterstützt, da kannst du eigentlich nur nochmal eine Runde kacken und das Ding wieder runterschmeißen.
Leider ist halt unter iOS Safari, also WebKit Safari der einzige Browser den es gibt, aber nicht mal lange, nicht mal lange.
Jo, ähm, deswegen, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wie, wie wahrscheinlich das ist.
Aber ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, also wenn, wenn wirklich Amazon und Microsoft und Google und die alle anfangen am,
sagen wir mal, am gleichen Strang zu ziehen, weil die sagen, fuck Leute, IPv6 ist für'n Arsch
und wir brauchen aber mehr Adressen, wir kommen mit IPv4 partout nicht aus, selbst mit unseren Milliarden, die wir haben, um noch irgendwelche Reste aufkaufen zu können,
dass die irgendeine ganz abartige IPv4 Erweiterung bauen.
So IPv4,5, sowas in der Richtung.
Wo dann so ganz komische Dinge gemacht werden, wie zum Beispiel
Man benutzt irgendwelche undefinierten Bytes im Header und wenn das dritte Byte gesetzt
ist an dieser Stelle, nur dann musst du in diesen Header gucken und dann hast du noch
vier weitere Bytes frei für zusätzliche Adressen, so ganz komisches Zeug, so ganz
komisches zeug so dass man dann quasi dass man dann quasi ipv4 adressen irgendwie irgendwie so in der in der richtung schreiben würde
also das normale ipv4 adresse und dass man dann irgendwie sowas sowas schreiben würde irgendwie keine ahnung
Warte mal seh ich ja so und das ist dann quasi dass sie dann irgendwie gucken okay das ist ja eigentlich ein privates netz aber
Aber, dass so und soviel Debite ist auf... ist... ist gesetzt und das in Kombination bedeutet, wir müssen noch die... die anderen zwei Header-Felder auswerten oder sowas.
Ganz ehrlich, die Chancen dafür, finde ich, sind gar nicht so weit... also, ich kann's schlecht einschätzen, ich bin nicht der Hardcore-Netzwerk... Netz... Netzwerk... ähm... Standard-Kenner.
Aber die Sache ist halt die, wenn Microsoft und Google und Apple und Azure und ganz Sachen
da mit dabei sind, die haben doch alles in der Hand, die haben die Browser in der Hand,
die haben die Betriebssysteme in der Hand, die haben die Clouds und die Serveranwendungen
in der Hand, die könnten das theoretisch machen, ja?
Also, ich glaube nicht, dass der Tag kommt, dass wir sagen, ey, IPv6, alles, was jetzt
über IPv4 erreichbar ist, ist jetzt über IPv6 erreichbar.
Und wenn die großen IT-Konzerne damit Probleme haben, die großen IT, und viele den Druck
dort spüren, ja, bei Amazon, bei Microsoft, bei Facebook, bei Google, bei allen, die denken
sich irgendeinen Hack aus, der rückwärts kompatibel ist zu IPv4, der es noch komplizierter
machen wird, aber ihn für die nächsten Jahre Luft verschafft.
Wie auch immer der aussehen wird, wir finden da schon irgendwas.
Du hast dir gerade ein OpenVM-Tools in Wayland angeschaut.
Ja, das ist, das suckt.
Die, ganz ehrlich, Wayland in Verbindung mit VMs ist halt voll für'n Arsch.
Was für mich dann halt Wayland voll für'n Arsch macht,
weil ich benutze hauptsächlich Linux in einer VM.
Ja, wie man hier sieht.
Ich bin erst wie bei der Zappix alle wie weit bin ich denn im Chat hinten dran?
Das soll tatsächlich ganz nice sein, aber ich kann mit PRTG nie zufrieden werden, weil
es Windows-only ist.
Also der Server.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Ich hatte das ja auch mal eine Weile bei mir daheim am Start, weil ich mir gedacht habe,
sowas simples reicht doch aber reicht doch nicht für mich
das habe ich relativ schnell gemerkt reines ist up down monitoring bringt mir
daheim nichts ich will auch mal wissen wie sieht es mit der festplatten
auslastung aus für die kiste für die für die kiste wo videos drauf gespeichert
werden oder ich will auch mal wissen irgendwie wie war dann die cpu auslastung
heute nacht und sowas kannst du mit abterm kuba nicht machen deswegen ich
habe ein subx bei mir lokal mit dem ich aber auch nicht wirklich happy bin
Würdest du sagen, Unternehmen sollen möglichst viel IT outsourcen und eher selbst machen?
Also es gibt ja durchaus Mittelwege, die man nehmen kann.
Ich glaube, das ist auch ganz sinnvoll.
Man muss nicht jeden Furz selber machen.
Outsourcen kann ja alles mögliche sein.
Es muss ja nicht automatisch gleich zu irgendwelchen Indern, die weder richtig Deutsch noch Englisch können, outsourced werden.
Sondern man kann irgendwelche Dienstleister vor Ort nehmen.
Man kann sich vielleicht komplett was fertig einkaufen.
Man kann vielleicht im europäischen Ausland irgendwas nehmen.
Ähm, man kann viele größere Unternehmen, irgendwelche Tochterfirmen, die das nebenbei machen.
Also, das macht, denke ich, durchaus Sinn.
Man muss da aber einen sinnvollen Mittelweg finden.
So dieses Alles oder Nichts ist meistens keine gute Idee.
Amazing, danke für den Sub!
War es bisher immer? Das war ja meine Frage dazu.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das bei PHP immer noch so ist, dass die keinen eigenen Webserver mitbringen.
Boah!
Ich habe die Performance-Sachen jetzt echt nicht mehr im Kopf.
Also ich kann dir sagen, dass das größte System, das ich betreut habe, war für 50.000
Außendienstmitarbeiter.
Natürlich haben nicht immer rund um die Uhr alle 50.000 Leute gearbeitet.
Aber selbst wenn du davon ausgehst, dass nur die Hälfte der an dem Tag gearbeitet haben,
trotzdem ein bisschen was los ich kann aber ich kann ich habe die ich habe die
monitor wand noch vor mir also die die traffic die traffic einheiten waren auf
jeden fall in gigabyte aber ich kann es dir aus dem kopf echt nicht mehr sagen
wie viel traffic und request das waren ungefähr
30.000 die Sekunde oder so, meine Requests sagen ja auch nicht wirklich so viel aus.
Können ja auch wenige Requests sein und das was resultiert an Last auf irgendwelchen Datenbanken
und in der Anwendung oder irgendwelche Berechnungen können viel sein.
Keine Ahnung, also ich kann dir sagen 50.000 Leute haben es täglich benutzt.
Ja, das stimmt, MySQL ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Oder vielleicht macht man es ja auch schlicht und ergreifend einfach falsch.
Ich meine, wenn man eine relationale Datenbank so als Art Key-Value-Store benutzt, ja dann
muss man sich nicht wundern, wenn die Performance zackt.
Wobei Postgres kann es ja mittlerweile mit den passenden Extensions ganz gut.
Postgres kann prinzipiell alles, also ich weiß eh nicht, warum man noch eine andere Datenbank als Postgres benutzen sollte.
Ich meine, für so klassische Aufgaben.
Wenn man sowas verteiltes wie CassandraDB haben will, was sich weltweit in Sync hält in irgendwelchen Cloud-Geschichten, dann ist es wieder was anderes.
Aber als normale, relationale Datenbank verstehe ich nicht, warum man nicht einfach Postgres immer und für alles nimmt.
Ja, okay, jetzt muss ich mal die Stellenanzeige angucken hier, das ist schon mal komplett verdrängt.
Also erstmal, das erste, das erste was mir schon mal negativ auffällt, ich hab schon vergessen, wenn ich die Stellenanzeige geschickt habe.
Silver, du hast die Stellenanzeige geschickt, ne?
Also, das erste was mir schon mal auffällt, warum war das in der Welt ist das Ding wieder Microsoft Word Anzeige 2022 und 2024, alter.
Können die nicht mal einen PDF-Geschalt generieren?
Also was suchen sie denn?
Rari, Food International, aus der Luft, vom Land, aus dem Meer.
IT-Systemadministrator suchen sie.
Das macht mich immer schon ein bisschen skeptisch,
wenn sie das so allgemein schreiben.
Weil ich mein, das heißt dann im Endeffekt auch wieder einer für alles.
Windows, Linux,
Drucker,
Storage-Virtualisierung
Okay, schauen wir mal. Ist ein Lebensmittelimport hier frisch und tief ge- bla bla bla bla, Hamburg wird tausend Euro gekriegt.
Wir sind stolz darauf, dass für ca. 50 Mitarbeiter- Okay, das ist jetzt aber so mittelständlich ist das Ganze.
250 Mitarbeiter zur Unterstützung unseres IT-Teams in Hamburg suchen wir zum nächstmöglichen Zeitpunkt einen IT-Systemadministrator. Zu deinen Aufgaben zählen. Jetzt geht's los.
Installation und Administration der Infrastruktur im Microsoft-Umfeld.
Das klingt nach Active Directory und Windows-Shit.
Das wäre für mich schon ganz grausam.
Das klingt nach Windows, Active Directory und sonst...
Im Zweifelfall noch Internet-Information-Server...
Service... Server? Gut, also. Admin im Microsoft-Umfeld. Sicherstellen der Systemverfügbarkeit und
Behebung von Störungproblemen. Gut, das ist ja durchaus in Ordnung. Eskalation von Supports
an... Was? Eskalation von Supports an externe Dienstleister. Hä? Ich verstehe den Satz
Eskalation von Supports?
Welche Supports eskalierst du da?
Meinen die von Support-Tickets?
Aber warum sollte man Support-Tickets an externe Dienstleister eskalieren?
Meinen die, man macht bei einem externen Dienstleister Support-Tickets auf?
So nach dem Motto, keine Ahnung, unsere Klimaanlage ist kaputt
und man hat einen Dienstleister, der sich darum kümmert
und man macht ein Ticket beim Dienstleister auf, die Klimaanlage ist kaputt.
Weinen die das damit? Also ich verstehe den Satz nicht.
Der Satz ist aber bescheuert geschrieben.
Zusammenarbeit mit Systemhäusern.
Okay, ja.
Kann jetzt ja alle so nichts heißen.
Verantwortung des Update- und Patchmanagements sowie das Backup- und Recoverymanagements.
Ja, okay.
Äh, wenn man sich für Server zuständig ist, sollte man die auch updaten und patchen, das klingt ja sinnig.
Optimierung bestehender...
Uah, uah, ähm, Optimierung bestehender sowie Konzeptio...
Was?
Optimierung bestehender...
Bestehender was?
Ach, Systemlandschaften!
Optimierung bestehender sowie Konzeptionierung und Umsetzung neuer Systeme.
Sag mal, das ist, ich hab keine Ahnung von deutscher Grammatik, aber das ist doch nicht richtig geschrieben, der Satz, oder?
Da fehlt doch hier irgendwie ein Bindestrich oder ein Komma oder irgendwas.
Ist das wirklich richtig so?
ok also optimierung und optimierung bestehen da und konzeption und umsatz
neue systeme ja ok passt auch verwaltung von nutzern rollens
Oh, Active Directory, ich hab's doch gesagt, Leute, Kack Windows.
No, God!
No, God, please, no!
Fick dich weg, du Hobo-Först.
Das ist Windows und Active Directory.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, Leute.
Beschaffung, Test und Wartung von Hardware und teilweise Software.
Beschaffung.
Gehen wir mal kurz in Saturn und holen eine USB-Festplatte.
Ja gut, die meinen bestellen bei irgendeinem Dienst.
Gut, dass du da mitmachst und so, das ist ein kleinerer Laden, dass du da ein bisschen was mitmachst, das klingt ja noch in Ordnung.
Fachliche Begleitung von Projekten zur Weiterentwicklung der IT-Landschaft.
Ey, du bist also quasi Ansprechpartner.
Okay, damit ist es vorbei.
Damit ist die Sache gelaufen.
Also ich hätte ja ich hätte ja bis hierhin ja
Also diese sachen die ich hier markiert habe dass das hätte ich ja noch mit einem auge zugedrückt
Hätte ich gesagt okay das ist vielleicht nicht sonderlich optimal geschrieben aber es ist ein kleiner laden und
Ja das passt noch irgendwie aber spätestens wenn die alle support der anwender
da wäre da wäre für mich komplett vorbei die suchen seit mitte 2022 gut
warum wollen warum warum suchen wir uns als im jahr schon die suchen seit genau
einem jahr ok es geht noch weiter heißt es
kommt mal weiter du passt zu uns wenn du
eine ausbildung zum fachinformatiker für systemintegration oder vergleichbare
Ausbildung mit vier bis
Vier bis zehn Jahren Berufserfahrung
jetzt war also
Was ist wenn ich elf Jahre Berufserfahrung habe?
Also entweder schreibst du leute entweder schreibst du vier Jahre die die stellen anzeige muss man speichern die ist dies
Pogge
Ja ne, wir speichern es einfach so.
Die brauche ich für's nächste Video.
Wo kommen wir eigentlich bei Rari raus?
Ist das denn ihr Webshop?
Okay.
Was?
Ah, die Seite sieht auch ein bisschen...
Sieht entweder nach komischem Wordpress-Template aus oder...
Naja.
Ne, wobei, ne, die Seite ist okay.
Die geht vollkommen in Ordnung.
Was mich irritiert hat, ist dieses Bild hier oben drinne.
Okay, ich meine, guck mal Leute, entweder schreibt man mit 4 Jahren oder mit mindestens 4 plus Jahren oder wie auch immer Berufserfahrung, aber warum schreibt man denn 4 bis 10?
Also ich meine, was ist, wenn ich 11 habe?
Oder 3?
Ich meine, okay, 3 kann man sagen ist zu wenig, aber überhaupt, ich meine, warum?
Warum?
Warum überhaupt 4?
Ich mein das da oben
sieht jetzt nicht sonderlich advanced
aus muss ich sagen
advance machts wahrscheinlich
der Laden
drumherum
Es ist halt ziemlich viel gemixt
und Support für den Anwender ist halt auch komplett
komplett für'n Arsch
Ja okay du meinst einer mit 11 Jahren hat kein Bock
fürs Gehalt das zu machen okay das kann natürlich sein
Naja, empfinde ich aber trotzdem ein bisschen komisch geschrieben.
Ganz ehrlich, denen wird auch jemand reichen, der frisch mit der Ausbildung fertig ist,
oder vielleicht ein Jahr Berufserfahrung hat, und sich halt im Windows-AD-Bereich auskennt.
Die wollen einen Windows-Admin, der AD-Ahnung hat.
Das ist das, was die im Kern wollen.
Im Kern wollen die einen Windows-Admin, der sich mit Active Directory auskennt.
kennt. Soweit alles andere. Wo macht man wann welche Support-Tickets auf? Und was für Projekte
gibt's? Und wo kann ich Hardware bestellen und sowas? Das ist kein Skill, den man haben
muss und den man in der Stellenanzeige suchen muss. Das ist was, das zeigst du den Leuten,
wenn sie da sind. Das ist nix, was du im Vorfeld können musst. Das macht eh jeder anders.
So, also wie geht's da weiter?
Gute Kenntnisse im Bereich Netzwerkadministration, LAN, WAN, Routing, Firewalls, VPN und so weiter.
Gut, dass du neben deinem Windows Camper natürlich noch alles Netzwerkmäßige mitmachen musst,
war ja zu erwarten, war ja zu erwarten, ja.
Fundierte Erfahrung mit Microsoft SQL, RDS, meinen die Datenbanken?
Also, Relationale Datenbanken, oder was meinen die da? Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Microsoft Server SSQL, oder wie manche sagen würden, SQL.
Exchange MonkaS.
Power Client OS. Okay, was zum Teufel ist Client OS?
Ah, ich dachte, das ist... Ich mein, was ein Client OS ist, ist mir klar. Also ein Client OS... Wahrscheinlich was die Windows-Anwender auf ihren Rechern haben, aber ich dachte, es gibt irgendein Produkt, was sich Client OS nennt oder sowas.
Dich mit Virtualisierungen speziell für MWare ausge- Ach, das auch noch?
Ah ja, du machst Netzwerk, du machst Windows Active Directory, Endanwender Support, Hardware
Software Bestellung, arbeitest bei Projekten mit und machst nebenbei noch Virtualisierung,
Netzwerk und Exchange und sowas?
Klar.
Einen proaktiven, selbstständigen, verantwortungsvollen Arbeitsstil und schnelle Auffassungsgabe hast.
Ich find's immer komisch, wenn die Leute sowas in die Bewerbung schreiben.
Weil jetzt mal ehrlich, jetzt mal ehrlich.
Gibt es irgendjemand, der sich dort bewirbt und im Vorstellungsgespräch dann sagt so
Übrigens, also meine proaktive, selbstständige, verantwortungsvolle Arbeitsstile und schnelle Auffassungsgabe habe ich nicht.
Oder der dann sagt, ah ne, dann bewerbe ich mich nicht, wenn alles andere passiert.
Irgendwie, das ist so vollkommen redundant, dass jemand, der in der IT arbeitet, ein bisschen was im Hirn haben muss.
Ja, okay, ich finde es komplett überflüssig, das reinzuschreiben, weil ernsthaft, wenn sich irgendwie der übelste Pega-3-Head-Typ da bewirbt,
Dann stellst du halt nicht ein. Das kannst du doch eh im Vorfeld null drauf geben.
Niemand würde sich deswegen dort nicht bewerben.
Niemand denkt von sich, Alter, ich bin nicht proaktiv, selbstständig und verantwortungsvoll genug. Ich bewerb mich da nicht.
Ja, das kannst du überall reinschreiben und dadurch, dass du es überall reinschreiben kannst, kannst du es auch überall rauslassen.
Ja, Chico, was ist los?
Die Katze ist bei mir an der Tüte.
Katze ist am Start.
Ist reingeflitzt hier ins Arbeitszimmer und sitzt jetzt auf dem Schrank und guckt mich
an.
Und jetzt?
Ja, Chico, was jetzt?
Ich habe keine Leckerlis.
Ich sitze jetzt oben auf dem Schrank und will Knusprigecken oder irgendwie sowas haben.
Gibt es jetzt nicht?
Ihr müsst nicht gucken.
Ihr gebt...
Ich gucke die jetzt einfach nicht weiter an.
Okay, also weiter.
Kommunikation sowie hohe Kunden- und Serviceorientierung.
Dieses Blabla, das kannst du einfach komplett weglassen.
Also es würde niemand davon abhalten sich zu bewerben.
Und umgedreht würde auch niemand sagen, nee das hab ich nicht.
Also kannst du eigentlich komplett rauslassen diese Sprüche.
Auch mal mit anpacken kannst.
Ja gut, die bestellte Hardware muss natürlich auch hochgetragen werden, ist schon logisch.
Reise...
Alter, die wollen auch jetzt...
Sag mal, kann das sein?
Kann das sein ich glaube ich habe ein system entdeckt leute in dieser stellen an diese dieser stellenbeschreibung
Die beschissensten sachen stehen immer im letzten punkt
Hier oben steht alles soweit okay
support für den endanwender
Hier soweit würde ich sagen zwar ziemlich ppg aber irgendwie ja passt und als ende kommt reisebereitschaft
Ich mein reisebereitschaft und support für den anwender das ist ja in kombination
Kombination schon Mal Komplettes K.O. Kriterium Deswegen bewirbt sich Dabei Wahrscheinlich auch Keiner also Keiner der IrGendwie von den Anderen Sachen Ahnung hat
Und Wahrscheinlich bist du dann auch der Einzige IT-Typ den sie haben
Wir bieten dir einen Arbeitsplatz an dem du tatsächlich gefordert wirst der dir ausreichend Möglichkeiten bietet sich selbst hat Irgendjemand schon Mal gedacht
Ich meine, ich kenne das, da schreiben viele rein, ja, aber habt ihr schon mal gedacht, wenn ihr nach Bewerbung guckt und euch so fragt, hm, wie würde für mich dann ein guter Arbeitsplatz aussehen?
Hat dann das, ist das Erste, an was ihr denkt? Ja, ich suche einen Arbeitsplatz, an dem du tatsächlich gefordert wirst und dir ausreichend Möglichkeit bietet, dich selbst weiterzuentwickeln.
Ja, in gewisser Weise ist das, spielt das sicherlich mit rein, aber nicht so in dieser Art und Weise, wie sie es schreiben.
Also ich wähle einen Arbeitsplatz, wo es mich interessiert, die Themen, die da gemacht werden.
Und ja, natürlich will ich auch irgendwie Möglichkeiten haben, mal was Neues zu machen, was anderes zu machen.
Aber wahrscheinlich habe ich da eine komplett andere Vorstellung als die, die den Satz geschrieben haben.
Eine leistungsgerechte Vergütung. Im Ernst, wahrscheinlich bezahlen die 40k im Jahr oder sowas.
Eine Unternehmenskultur, die Freiräume bietet, Verantwortung überträgt und auf partnerschaftliche
...
Ja, das könnt ihr alle sagen.
Das sagen ja auch alle so blablabla im Endeffekt.
Da kann man halt nichts drauf geben.
Flache Hierarchien und offene Türen der Initiativen sind eventuell ...
Sagen auch alle.
Obst es wirklich so machen, wirst du erst erfahren, wenn du da bist.
Was ist eine angemessene Skala nach der Ausbildung? Eine Ausbildung als was?
Eine reizvolle Tätigkeit in kleinen Teams mit offener Kultur.
Das ist auch so furchtbar nichtssagend.
Also ich finde beispielsweise Support für den Endanwender nicht sonderlich reizvolle Tätigkeit.
Fachinformatiker.
Ja schwer zu sagen, es hängt natürlich ein bisschen davon ab, in welcher Branche,
Vor allem in welchem Bundesland, in welchem Gebiet. Also ich kann nicht sagen, was ich bekommen habe.
Ich kann dir sagen, ich habe direkt nach der Ausbildung 33.500 bekommen, damals, vor 15 Jahren oder so, beim Provider noch.
Naja, nee, nee, nicht 15 Jahre.
Aber ohne Scheiß mittlerweile wirklich fast 15 Jahre.
Ähm, mir kommt es vor, als wäre es gestern gewesen, ohne Scheiß.
Krass, oder?
Krasser Scheiß, das kommt mir alles nicht so lange vor.
Na gut, also ich hab damals 33.500 bekommen, wenn du da jetzt die Inflation und sonst was reinrechnest, würde ich mal sagen, also unter 40k eher nicht.
Oder Chat, was sagt ihr dazu?
Es kommt aber wie gesagt sehr stark auf Branche und vor allem Region an.
an. Also unter 40k würde ich es auf keinen Fall machen. Vielleicht sollte man eher Richtung
45k mittlerweile sogar schon zielen. Das kann ich aber schwer einschätzen. Wie gesagt es
sehr auf Branche und vor allem halt auch auf die Region an, wo du bist.
Jetzt hast du in München, ja gut München gesurfelt.
Deswegen, ich glaube 45 ist durchaus, durchaus drin.
Wie gesagt, kommt auf die Region und auch die Branche an.
Finanzbranche bezahlt sehr gut, Versicherungsbranche bezahlt sehr gut, Pharmaindustrie bezahlt sehr gut, ähm, ja, das sind die drei, wo ich weiß, dass sie gut bezahlen.
So, also, wenn wir dein Interesse geweckt haben, überzeugt uns, also, mich würde das Interesse tatsächlich wecken, wenn sie wenigstens ihre Word-Vorlage ordentlich, nein, das Interesse würde mich ehrlich gesagt nie wecken,
Sie hätten ja wenigstens ihre Word-Vorlage und Zeilen-Render irgendwie im Griff haben können.
Bewerbung.
Ja, nice.
Okay, da weiß ich schon mal, wo ich mich nicht bewerbe.
Ich bewerbe mich generell nicht, nur für den Fall der Fälle, dass wieder einer fragt,
Max, suchst du schon wieder einen neuen Job?
Nein, nein, ich suche keinen neuen Job.
Ich bin eigentlich jetzt, ich bin zwei Monate dort, beim neuen Arbeitgeber
und bis jetzt eigentlich auch ganz happy beim neuen Arbeitgeber.
Ich werde jetzt auch erstmal bleiben.
Siehe dein Spoiler zu der Anzeige, kommt er hier noch im Chat oder habe ich den schon
überscrollt?
Ja, gehe ich auch von aus, dass viele nicht über IPv6 erreichbar sind.
Sodass man eine Public IPv4 bekommt, ist alles okay.
Was kommt zuerst, IPv6, Flächendenken oder ist ja das Dienungsnetzwerk?
Ja, ich glaube das kommt alles ziemlich zeitgleich.
Ich konnte noch fragen, ob Elder Scrolls 6 vielleicht vorher rauskommt oder Half-Life
3.
Also, wenn ihr mich fragen würdet, was setzt sich zuerst durch?
Oder, was kommt zuerst? IPv6?
Also, muss ich anders formulieren.
Half-Life 3?
Oder, dass alles was jetzt über IPv4 erreichbar ist, über IPv6 erreichbar sein wird?
Dann sage ich, Half-Life 3 kommt zuerst.
Eindeutig.
Weil, für Half-Life 3 gibt's ja...
...in irgendeiner Art und Weise noch ne...
...naja...
...semi-realistische Chance.
die Half-Life-Games waren immer super erfolgreich
und vielleicht haben sie
hat Gaben doch noch irgendwann mal Bock
und IPv6 wird sich halt flächendeckend, dass alles was jetzt IPv4
dann IPv6 verfügbar ist, wird halt nie passieren.
Finde ich auch eine gute Idee
mit IPv6-Only-Servern anzufangen
Weißt du, was ich noch viel besser bei Hetzner finde?
Server komplett ohne Public IP.
Das ging ja auch eine ganze Weile nicht.
Was ich ziemlich bescheuert fand.
Was ist eigentlich das Icon da vorne? Ah, TwitchCon.
Was ich ziemlich bescheuert fand, weil
es brauchen gar nicht
alle Server Public IPs.
Die wenigsten
die wenigsten Systeme
in der Cloud-Infrastruktur brauchen Public IPs.
Public IPs brauchen eigentlich nur die Eingänge oder vielleicht noch irgendwelche
VPN-Endpunkte oder irgendwelche Jump-Hosts, aber ansonsten braucht eigentlich nix
externe IPs
Was ist besser IPv6 und was ist der Unterschied zwischen IPv4?
Was besser ist und was der Unterschied ist, kann man relativ einfach erklären. Es gibt sehr viele Unterschiede. IPv6 ist ein komplett neues Protokoll
auch mit ganz vielen
Ähm, neuen Feinheiten.
Der hauptsächliche Unterschied ist, du hast mehr Adressen zur Verfügung mit IPv6.
Also nicht nur ein bisschen mehr, sondern irgendwie
einmal alle Atome im Universum mehr irgendwie. Es ist unglaublich viel mehr, was du zur Verfügung hast bei IPv6.
Und...
Ja, das ist eigentlich auch der einzige... Naja, nee, der stimmt nicht.
Das kann man so nicht sagen. IPv6 hat noch ein paar andere coole Sachen, zum Beispiel, dass sie native IPsec-Unterstützung haben und es gibt noch mehr.
Müsst ihr euch nachgucken. Ich mache ehrlich gesagt auch zu wenig, also ich mache relativ selten was mit IPv6, einfach weil es nicht so wirklich relevant ist.
Auch wenn das viele Letzwerker nicht gerne hören.
Als Trinken erinnern. Sehr gute Idee. Exzellent.
Hast du das? Nein? Was ist da? Habe ich nicht mitbekommen. Was ist da?
Haben sie die abgeschaltet, oder?
Leute, ich habe es doch letztens gesagt.
Wir hatten doch genau dieses Thema letztens im Stream.
Stream. Und da hab ich gesagt, mich wundert es, weil die Leute gesagt haben, benutzt doch einfach
Apollo, mich wundert es, dass die das überhaupt noch anbieten können, jetzt nachdem Reddit mit
ihrer AP und Geschiss angekommen ist. Und zack, bam, haben wir es mal wieder predicted im Stream.
Silver, hab ich irgendwo deinen Kram überlesen?
Stell in Beschreibung.
Da war noch nix, oder?
Der kommt noch, okay.
Meine Firma bezahlt mir vielleicht eine Einführung in Linux, kennst du einen guten Kurs oder ähnliches?
Nee.
Dafür mach ich das schon zu lang, keine Ahnung, was ein guter Einsteigerkurs ist oder wer
sowas anbietet.
Das sind 50 Mitarbeiter, was erwartest du, dass sie ein ganzes IT-Team haben?
Ja, weil das eine der wichtigsten Sachen für die ganze Firma wahrscheinlich ist.
Also in meinem Team kann ja auch durchaus mal 3, 4, 5 Leute sein.
Ja, würde ich erwarten, wenn ihnen das wichtig ist.
Gerade in heutigen Zeiten.
Da kann man sich nämlich auch drauf verlassen, was gescheit gemacht wird.
Ja, ich meine, wir haben auch alle 20 Jahre Kubernetes-Erfahrung, oder?
Ähm, ja, Sophie, Gaby, nee, Quatsch.
Das ist ja, das ist einfach nur, einfach nur Hex hier an der Stelle.
Ich hab Sophie gelesen gerade.
Ja, also ich, das denke ich auch an der Stelle.
Ach, RDS ist Remote Desktop Services. Okay, das passt auch besser in Windows-Geschiss rein.
Ist ja fast normal, wenn die Personalabteilung das schreibt. Vor allem, wenn die Personalabteilung
das schreibt, nicht in engerer Zusammenarbeit mit dem Team, was eigentlich die Leute sucht.
Tja, was sollen sie machen?
Was sollen sie denn machen?
Ich meine, du hast schon in gewisser Weise recht, also viele finden nix und viele bewerben
sich auch schon gar nicht mehr direkt, sondern lassen sich erstmal anschreiben und bewerben
sich dann.
Aber was sollen sie machen?
Weil, wenn die Leute suchen, können sie ja nicht sagen, naja, gut, wir ergeben uns und leben einfach damit.
Na gut, im Endeffekt müssen sie damit leben, weil sie niemanden mehr finden.
Aber die müssten im Prinzip schon ein bisschen das machen, was du sagst.
Sie müssten woanders aktiv werden.
Sie müssten zum Beispiel aktiv zeigen, dass sie ein guter Arbeitgeber sind.
Und zum Beispiel Leute, die eh schon innerlich keinen Bock mehr auf ihren aktuellen Job haben,
aber noch nicht richtig suchen, versuchen anzusprechen.
Was nicht so einfach ist, gerade wenn du so ne kleine 14-50-Mann-Firma bist, ähm...
Stell ich mir das, stell ich mir das schwierig vor,
dann müsstest du das von irgendwelchen Headhunter-Typen machen lassen,
die wahrscheinlich einfach nur Geld kosten und für den Laden auch keinen finden.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ich bin froh, dass ich nicht dort in der Personalabteilung arbeite und dafür zuständig bin.
Die haben es sicherlich nicht einfach gerade.
Spoiler, der jetzige Admin hat einen Windows-Klein mit 3.3.8.9 Internet-Exposure.
Ist das der jetzige Admin, dessen Chef, also der entschieden hat, also für den jetzt die
Stellenanzeige ersetzt wird, der jetzt ersetzt werden soll mit der Stellenanzeige, oder?
Das ist eine blöde Idee, Windows per ADP ins Internet zu hauen.
Das hat er wahrscheinlich gemacht, dass er von unterwegs darauf zugreifen kann,
weil die Firma nicht in der Lage war, ihm gescheite Remote-Arbeitsmöglichkeiten zu bieten.
Meistens hat er sowas einen Grund und der Grund ist öfters...
Also ne, muss ich anders sagen.
Der Grund, warum sowas gemacht wird, ist oftmals nicht die Unfähigkeit der Admin-Leute,
Sondern irgendwelche Randbedingungen, die sie dazu veranlassen, das zu machen.
Ich hab grad gedrunken.
Ah, jetzt will Checo wieder raus. Ja, Mensch, Checo, jetzt noch mal vorwärts.
So, also wie gesagt Leute, ich muss gleich ins Bett.
Bett getimed.
Ich mein, 22.10.
Ihr wisst was jetzt ist, oder?
Also zumindest auch, vor allem das, was ich jetzt schon so mir vorstellen kann, wie mistig das sein wird,
da müssten wir, die müssten mir 250k im Jahr bezahlen, wenn ich das machen würde.
Das, das kann einfach nur frustrierend und ätzend werden.
Das würde ich nicht machen.
Also, die müssten mir wirklich richtig Schmerzensgeld bezahlen dafür.
Also für so eine Viertelmillion im Jahr würde ich es machen.
Was sie selbstverständlich nicht bezahlt.
Für alles andere im Leben nicht.
Realistischer betrachtet, ich gehe davon aus, die bezahlen hier 40, 45k. Das ist wahrscheinlich
auch so ein Laden, die für ihre IT-Leute nicht viel Geld ausgeben wollen. Also, kommt bloß nicht
auf die Idee, dich bei sowas zu bewerben. Also, ich glaube, da machst du dir nur das Leben schwer mit.
2,3 in der Abschlussprüfung, ist nice. Das ist ein ziemlich gutes Ergebnis. Also,
Also viele sind diesmal wohl, hab ich glaube ich gelesen, weiß nicht ob das wirklich stimmt,
hat glaube ich sogar einer im Chat geschrieben.
Viele sind diesmal deutlich schlechter in der Abschlussprüfung und Hauptsache du hast
bestanden.
Eigentlich ist es egal, aber 2,3 ist doch wirklich gut.
Also nicht nur wirklich gut, auch praktisch in Worten gut.
Das ist immer noch da, aber ich habe eine Linux-VM auf der ich Root bin.
Einzige was ich auf meinem Windows-Notebook laufen habe ist Terminal im Fullscreen.
Also eigentlich wischt das Studio Coden darin, das Terminal im Fullscreen.
Ja, das bei AW, das geht bei fast allen, aber bei vielen Hosting Anbietern geht's nicht.
So bei reinen Hosting-Anbietern. Also bei Hetzner geht es beispielsweise noch gar nicht lang, dass du Server komplett ohne Public-IP oder jetzt halt auch zumindest mal ohne IPv4 buchen kannst.
Es ist aber ein guter Trend, weil wie gesagt, wenn man ein bisschen größere, ein bisschen umfangreichere Infrastruktur in der Cloud laufen hat, oder halt auch bei irgendwelchen Hosting-Anbietern laufen hat,
die meisten Kisten brauchen keine Public-IP. Wozu?
Solange die intern verbunden werden können.
Du brauchst deinen Eingang, also deinen Loadbalancer bzw. den Reverse-Proximizer, Public IP und vielleicht irgendwelche Admin-Geschichten brauchen noch Public IP, wo du dann da drüber reinkommst oder VPN-Endpunkte oder so. Ansonsten braucht halt nix Public IPs.
Das stimmt. Wobei man ja auch argumentieren könnte, dass NUT, und ich weiß, da schreien
jetzt die ganzen IPv6-Fans, aber ich finde, es ist trotzdem so, NUT automatisch ein Schutz
davor ist, dass du nicht aus Versehen Dinger freigibst, die du nicht freigeben willst.
Ja, natürlich kommen jetzt die Leute und sagen, aber NUT, wir wollen feiern wollen
mit IPv6, aber bei NUT ist es halt einfach vom Prinzip her ausgeschlossen, dass du was
freigeben kannst du kannst mit nackt nichts freigeben was du nicht also
selbst wenn du willst kannst du mit nackt nicht wirklich alles freigeben
Da hast du recht Chillflake.
wird es schon noch geben. Also ich hatte ja eine Frage bezüglich Lasse-Meilen-Betriebe.
Ich habe ein Synology DS216, was auch immer das für eins ist. So, so wolltest du das?
Aber sicherlich legal erworben und von deinem Datenträger ohne Umgehung des Kopierschutzes
gerippt, oder? Aber der Plex meint, dieser sei nicht leistungsfähig genug. Keine Ahnung,
Ich hab von Plex kein Schimmer.
Also wenn du transcoden willst, und das ist wahrscheinlich das Problem.
Wenn du transcoden willst, ja, das braucht Fettleistung, gerade wenn es 4K ist.
Also wenn du keine Möglichkeit hast, den Hardware zu transcoden, braucht das extremes CPU-Last.
H265?
Oder H264? Wahrscheinlich meistens H264.
4K transcoden on the fly?
Da kannst du...
...mal locker...
Naja, wenn du aktuell, mal angenommen du hast nur eine aktuelle 8-Kern-CPU, wobei dann hast
du auch in irgendeiner Art und Weise Hardware-Decoding.
Also wenn das Ding kein Hardware-Decoding hat und das ist komplett CPU-technisch am
Anschlag, wenn du transcoden willst, 4K on the fly transcoden, H264, kannst komplett
klicken. Wobei ich nicht weiß, wie gut das ausgestattet ist. Wenn du einfach nur streamen
willst ohne Transcone, was aber halt voraussetzt, dass dein Client das Format kann, in dem gestreamt
wird, dann sollte das gehen, aber keine Ahnung von Plex und auch nicht was Plex mit der,
also ich kenne die Hardware nicht, ich habe von Plex keine Ahnung, ich weiß auch nicht,
was Plex mit der Meldung sagen will.
Ist doch nicht verkehrt, wenn die erstmal checken, ob ihre Mitarbeiter geistig irgendwie
halbwegs kompatibel sind.
Mein je nachdem was da gefragt wird kann das auch ausatmen an twitch mittlerweile a vor eins keine ahnung
Luca danke für den sub
Wie gesagt geht set
Meine Firma, wo ich meine Physi-Ausbildung am 1.8. anfange,
Dinger mit geografischen Informations- und Betriebs-Informations-Systemen,
dir das zu... Nö.
Ne, aber da kannst du einfach mal nachgoogeln, was die Firma macht,
die haben doch bestimmt ne Website.
Wahrscheinlich ist es einfacher, auf der Website von der Firma zu gucken,
anstatt mich zu fragen, ob ich weiß, was es ist.
Und ansonsten keine Ahnung was das sein soll.
Ich meine geografische Informationssysteme, das kann alles mögliche sein.
Die könnten auch irgendwelche Lora-Sensoren für Bauern herstellen,
dass sie die Wässerung ihrer Kornfelder überwachen können.
Du meinst, wie heißt das, UPnP und so Geschiss, ne?
UPnP geht aber nur, wenn der Client das auch kann und wenn der Router das kann.
Das würde ich eh prinzipiell ausschalten.
UPnP ist Shit.
Und ansonsten, was du machen kannst, was aber mit nahezu allen, also was mit jeder NAT-Lösung
funktioniert ist diese diese nut hole geschichte wo du einen externen server
aufbaust deine informationen weitergibt an den anderen der sich verbindet und
der dann quasi als als absender so tut ich krieg ich krieg das mit diesem nut
hole punching gerade im kopf nicht zusammen dass das das geht aber
prinzipiell immer. Besser ein paar Ausnahmen. Aber zumindest diese UPnP-Geschichte geht nur,
wenn der Router das kann und wenn der Client das kann. Okay, wenn es ein C-Roll ist,
hast du eh geschissen. Dann ist da mit großartigem Streaming wahrscheinlich nix.
So, Leute, ich hab's geschafft!
Schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid!
Jetzt ist Bett-Getime!
Bis denn, macht's gut, CU!
Was?
Preise sinken weiter, sehr gut.
Vielleicht sind's ja irgendwann mal wieder auf dem, wo man für sich Raspberry Pis kaufen
kann.
Bis denn, macht's gut, CU!
Ja, Timer, du bist zu spät, CU!